opencv is a popular python library for
real-time computer vision
this course comes directly from the
creators of opencv
and is the perfect course for beginners
at the end of the course there's an
interview with the ceo of opencv
dr malik and he talks to you about how
to get a job in computer vision and
ai in 2005 for the first time in human
history
an autonomous vehicle traveled 132 miles
through the mojave desert to win the 2
million dollar
darpa grand challenge the name of the
car was stanley
and it used a computer vision library
called opencv
hello everybody i'm satya malik and i'm
thrilled to help you get started with
opencv
built over 20 years opencv is the most
extensive computer vision library
in the world it is downloaded between
one to two million times a week
and it contains over 2500 optimized
algorithms
to build computer vision and ai
applications opencv
is the first library you need to learn
welcome to this free getting started
series
we designed it for absolute beginners
all you need
is an intermediate level of programming
knowledge and python
opencv is vast it is not possible to
cover all aspects of the library
in the short period of time this series
is your first step
it will help you get started the
material in the series
will be covered using jupyter notebooks
we
will go over every notebook in a video
to help you understand
the code the first few notebooks are all
about
basics what are images and videos
how do we represent them inside opencv
what opencv functions do we use to read
write and manipulate photos and videos
next we will go over image enhancement
and filtering our objective in this
series is
also to give you a glimpse into
applications you can build
using opencv functions we will go over
different image transformations
and show you how to align two images the
same idea can be modified slightly to
create
beautiful panoramas next we will dip
our toes into computational photography
and create
high dynamic range images by combining
photos taken using different exposures
into one single beautifully lit photo
opencv also implements many classical
machine learning algorithms and has an
entire module
dedicated to deep learning inference we
will learn
how to implement face detection and
object tracking
finally we will wrap up the series by
learning how to use
deep learning module for object
detection
and pose estimation it's going to be
very interesting
that's all we will cover in this getting
started series
and after completing this series i
encourage you to go
and take a look at the free content at
opencv.org
and learn opencv.com and when you're
ready
for structured learning and you're
seeking mastery
in computer vision and ai check out our
courses at opencv.org
courses i wish you all the best
in your learning path but today let's
get started with opencv
hi everyone in this introductory video
we're going to be covering several basic
image processing concepts related to
working with images
all this material is very essential and
we'll be using python and specifically
opencv
to demonstrate for example how to read
an image and display it
understanding how images are represented
by data of the differences between
grayscale images and color images
and specifically what it means to have
multiple channels in color images and
then finally
how to save images so just a couple of
things i wanted to mention before we get
started
is that we'll be using jupiter notebooks
for most of these demonstrations
mainly because it's a very convenient
way to display intermediate results
and has some very nice documentation
features that make it easy to present
code and supporting material
so in some cases we might actually use
python scripts for specific applications
but mainly we'll be using jupyter
notebooks
in this series so to get started i just
wanted to talk a little bit about
this first section here where we're
importing some required libraries
one thing i wanted to mention is that
when you use jupyter notebooks
you want to use this map plot lib inline
specification here
so that we can display images directly
in the notebook and then one other thing
that we'll be using in this notebook is
this ipython function
image which will allow us to display and
render images directly in the notebook
so in this first example here below
we're going to actually use that
function
to display two checkerboard images here
they're both black and white
checkerboard images
and the first one here is 18 by 18
pixels and this next one here is 84
pixels by 84 pixels and you can see that
if we
read in those files and display them
directly in the notebook
that their actual size is uh
faithfully rendered so the 18 by 18
pixel image is quite small here
and you can see the difference between
the two images
and one of the reasons we wanted to
start with that is because generally
we'll be using opencv to actually
read in an image and store that data in
memory as a numpy
array and then working with that numpy
array
in terms of manipulating the image or
saving the image or displaying the image
and in those cases we're really
displaying a mathematical representation
of the image and not necessarily
a faithful representation of the image
within the browser itself so that'll
become more clear as we um
proceed further through this notebook
but we just wanted to draw that
distinction
so let's scroll down here and take a
look at the first function that we're
going to be using from
opencv before we get started though i
just wanted to mention that
when we introduced new functions we
decided to include this
documentation section here in the
notebooks that summarize the functional
syntax
i describe some information about the
arguments required maybe some
optional arguments and then the um we've
also provided
the opencv documentation links so
we're not going to go through these
sections in great detail but we will
refer to them when we describe some of
the code
in these notebooks so let's just take a
look at how we use i am read and in this
first example here we're reading in the
smaller checkerboard image
notice that the first argument is just
the file name for the
for the image itself which can be either
a relative or an absolute path name
and notice also there's actually an
optional second argument here
and here we're indicating zero and if
you look back up here in the
documentation section you see that zero
corresponds to a flag
that specifies that we want to read this
image in as a grayscale image
and we'll talk more about this further
below but i just wanted to point out
that
there is an optional second flag here
that we'll make use of quite a bit
and then the return from imread is a
numpy 2d array representing the image
and i can print that information here
using the print command
and you'll see uh down here there's the
data that represents that image
so it's 18 rows and 18 columns and
each of the values represents the pixel
intensities
for each of those pixels and notice that
they're in the range of 0 to 255
because this image is being represented
by an unsigned 8-bit
integer so let's scroll down here a bit
further and print some information
associated uh with the image so
drawing your attention up here uh to
this code block
we're using the shape and d type methods
uh
of that numpy array object to print out
both the
image size and the data type so here you
can see it's 18 by 18 and
unsigned in as we had pointed out and so
at this point
let's talk about how to display the
image so here in this code block we're
using the
matplotlib function i am show to display
a representation of that image and so
here we're just passing it
the numpy array that represents that
image and you'll see this
plot below so notice that this is
actually a plot or mathematical
representation
of that image but it's not 18 pixels
a wide on my screen it's it's just a
plot representing 18 pixels and so you
can see the axes here correspond to
18 by 18. also notice that it's not
black and white as we expected
but looks like yellow and dark navy blue
and the reason for that is that
matplotlib
uses color maps to represent image data
and in this particular case it's using
some other
color map rather than a grayscale color
map so
if we want to display this as an actual
grayscale image we need to
actually set the color map so we're
going to do that here in this
in this section where we call i am show
with an optional
argument uh color map equals gray and if
we set the color map equal to gray then
then we get what we expected a black and
white uh
image representation so let's take a
look at another example
here we're reading in another
checkerboard image of the same size
but this has pixel intensities that
range from 0 to 255 with lots of gray
values in between so you can see
that reflected here in the matrix itself
and then when we plot the image you can
see the grayscale representation of
those middle tone values
so it's not a very interesting image but
it demonstrates just the idea that a
grayscale
image can have values between 0 and 255
and that those are represented
on a continuum from
pure black to pure white so now we're
ready to talk about
color images so let's scroll down to
this next section here where we're going
to read in
a high-resolution image of the coca-cola
logo
so here we're using the ipython image
function to do that and we're rendering
that image in the browser
and um let's scroll down to this next
section now and actually use opencv
imread to read that in
and store that data in a in a matrix
so here we're storing that information
in this coke underscore image
object notice that when we read it in we
specified an optional second argument of
one here
so it's going to read in this image as a
color image
and it turns out this image is in a rgb
format so there's three channels one for
red green and blue and when we print out
the size and the data type of this
matrix you can see it's 700 by 700 by 3
where 3 is the number of channels
but notice that when we display the
image down here using matplotlib i am
show
comes up blue which is unexpected and
the reason for that is because
opencv actually uses a um a different
format for storing the channel
information than most other applications
so for rgb images opencv uses a
channel order of bgr rather than rgb
so matplotlib is expecting this to be
rgb
but the way that opencv read this into
the matrix it stores it in bgr
so it ends up looking blue unless we
swap the order of the channels so that's
what this next bit of code down here
does
in this block here we're taking this
coke image array
and swapping the order of the channels
here that's what this syntax does here
it reverses the order of that last
member of the array
and now we're going to display that and
it comes up
red and white as we expected so that's
just something to be aware of whenever
you're working with opencv you need to
be aware of the channel order convention
and we'll see that come up again and
again in these notebooks
so now we're going to take a look at
splitting and merging color channels in
this next section here
splitting and merging um are pretty
straightforward
in opencv and they can refer to this
documentation link for more details
but uh here's the example so let's just
go over that
here on this first line we're using i am
read to read in a color image
and notice here for the optional
argument we're actually specifying the
flag
as opposed to one for specifying that we
want to read this in as a color image
and we're going to
store that result in image underscore nz
underscore bgr and i specifically
used bgr in the name of the variable to
remind myself that
that's what this represents since we're
reading it in using opencv
and now on this next line i'm going to
call the opencv split
function to take that multi-channel
image and split it into its components b
g and r and so each of these uh
variables
represent a 2d numpy array that contain
the pixel intensities for those
color channels so in this next section
of code here we're simply going to use
um
i am show to display each of those
representations
as a grayscale map and then this last
bit of code here takes those individual
channels and uses the merge function
to merge them back into what should be
the original image and we'll call that
image merged here and we'll show that as
well
so now taking a look at the images below
we've got the
red green and blue grayscale
representation
of each of the channels and then the
merged output over here to the right
and it's worth a little bit of a mention
here but you can get some intuition by
just
taking a look at the original image so
for example this lake
is a kind of a turquoise blue if you
will it's got some green and blue in it
for sure and probably very little red
so if you now go back to these channels
you can see that the red channel
for the portion of the lake is is low
meaning there's not much red component
in that color so that's why it's darker
it's closer to zero
and notice that the green and the blue
channels are fairly high intensity for
their respective
colors so that's indicating that the
color of that water there
has a very little red in it but quite a
bit of green and definitely quite a bit
of blue
so that's kind of the interpretation so
next let's
scroll down here and talk about another
function in opencv
called cvt color this allows you to
essentially convert between color spaces
so
the syntax here is you supply a source
image
and a code indicating the type of
conversion you want
and the the result will be a different
color space
so this is easiest to talk about just
with an example so we have a very simple
example here converting from bgr to rgb
so we're calling cvt color and we're
passing it the bgr representation
of that image that we read in above and
we're specifying a code of
bgr to rgb so this is simply a flag
indicating to opencv that
we're supplying it a bgr image and we
want to convert it to rgb
and so i'm storing that here in this new
variable and then i'm going to use
i am show to display that and this is
what we expect we're just simply
displaying the original image
but if you look at the documentation for
cbt color you'll see that there's all
kinds of
color codes that allow you to convert
between color spaces and so that's the
subject of this next section of the
notebook here
where we are going to convert
that image to a different color space so
in this first line up here we're going
to convert the
bgr representation of that image to an
hsv
representation so hsv stands for hue
saturation and value
and that's another color space that's
often used in image processing and
computer vision
and so we're going to store that result
in a in a variable named
image underscore hsv so now i can split
those channels just like we did above
and get the h s and v components
and just like the example above i'm
going to plot all four images here
the three channels and then the original
image
for example uh hue represents
the color of the image saturation
represents the intensity of the color
and v represents the value so you can
think of saturation as being
a pure red versus a dull red and you can
think of value as being how light or
dark
the color is irrespective of the color
itself
and then hue is more like the um
representation of the actual color
so just as an example in this next
section here we're going to actually
modify
one of the channels so if you look at
this first line of code i'm going to
take the um
the current q value and add 10 to it so
we're just shifting the
where we are on the color spectrum and
then i'm going to merge
that new channel with the original s and
v
channels and get a merged image and then
i'm going to use a cvt color to
convert that from hsv to rgb
so now i've modified one of the channels
i've merged it and now i've converted it
and then i'm going to use i am show
below
to display each of the color channels
and then the modified
merged image so you can see here that
the modified image
because we've changed the hue looks
different from the original image up
here
so that's a brief introduction to color
channels and color spaces
and now we're ready to move on with
final section of this notebook
having to do with saving images and
writing them to disk
so there's a function in opencv similar
to imread it's called i am right
and it's very simple to use you simply
pass in the file name that you want to
save the file as and then the
the image itself and so there's an
example here
we're going to use the i am write
function and we're going to give it a
file name new zealand lake underscore
saved
to indicate that we're actually saving
this from our notebook
and we're passing it this image that
we've been working with here
in bgr format and then on the very next
line here we're going to use that
ipython image function to read that file
back in and render it
right here in the browser and then the
last thing we wanted to conclude with
is just taking this image and using i am
read to
read it in uh both as a color image
here and as a grayscaled image here and
then print out both of those
arrays and notice that the first one
read in as a color image has got three
channels and the one that's read in his
gray scale has got just the single
channel
so we did cover quite a bit of material
in this notebook and we hope it's been a
good reference for you
there is one other thing that we'd like
to discuss but not from within the
notebook so we're going to move over to
a development environment
and spend just a few minutes talking
about the differences between matplotlib
i am show and opencv item show so we'll
continue on there in just a second
okay so here we are in the development
environment and uh we put this script
together
uh so that we could demonstrate some of
the differences between
the matplotlib version of i am show and
the opencv version of i am show
and we start by just reading in two
colored images this first one here is a
color checkerboard image and then the
second one here is the coca-cola logo
and then this very first block of code
here is using the matplotlib
version of i am show to display the
checkerboard image
and we've seen examples of that before
in the notebook
the rest of this code is all centered
around using the opencv version of i am
show
and there's uh some extra code here
that's required in order to use this
properly
so the first thing we do is uh create a
named window here
and then we call the opencv version of i
am show passing at the named window
and then the image we want to display in
the window
and notice right after this we call a
wait key function
and the argument to that function is the
number of milliseconds that
this window will be displayed so eight
seconds in this case
uh if we didn't uh call this weight key
function then the
im show function would display the
window indefinitely and there'd be no
way to actually
exit the window so the weight key
function is meant to be used in
conjunction with the i am show
function so then we're going to continue
on and and perform the same
set of actions except with a different
image the coke image in this case just
so you can see the dynamic behavior
and then finally down here in this third
section we're going to do the same thing
displaying the checkerboard image again
but this time we're going to pass
a 0 to the weight key function so rather
than displaying
the image for 8 seconds 0
means it'll be displayed indefinitely
unless any key on the keyboard is struck
so this allows you to have user input
rather than waiting for a specific time
to pass
and then there's one other option down
here that you could use in conjunction
with a while loop
you could call the im show function
inside of a while loop
and then monitor the keyboard to only
exit the loop if the user types a
specific key
like for example the lowercase q to quit
so let's take a look at
how this behaves when we run the
demonstration
so here we're displaying the image using
matplotlib
and i can go ahead and exit that window
and now this checkerboard image is going
to be displayed using the opencv version
of i am show but only for eight seconds
and then the same with the coca-cola
logo and notice that i i'm not able to
actually exit the window i have to wait
the eight seconds and now we're back to
the checkerboard image but in this case
we passed a zero to the wait key
function so this is just going to be
displayed indefinitely until i hit
until i hit a key on the keyboard so
i'll go ahead and hit the space bar and
this will disappear
and now we're in the while loop and the
coca-cola image is
being displayed and if i hit uh the
spacebar nothing happens
because the weight key function is being
monitored
for the user to type a lowercase q so
lowercase q is going to be the only key
that will allow this to actually exit so
i'll go ahead and hit the lowercase
q and so that's another way for you to
use the opencv version of im show
so we hope that gives you a better feel
for some of the subtleties associated
with using the opencv
version of i am show and that's all we
wanted to cover in this section
in this video we're going to be talking
about basic techniques for manipulating
images which include changing the values
of individual pixels within an image
as well as some other useful
transformations like cropping resizing
and flipping images
these are all very standard
transformations and
very easy with the help of opencv
functions so let's
get started and take a look at the first
example below here where we're going to
manipulate individual pixels this is the
image that we worked with in the first
video it's the
black and white checkerboard that's 18
pixels wide and 18 pixels tall
so let's scroll down here a bit further
and talk about how to access uh
individual pixels within this uh image
so let's suppose we wanted to
access this very first pixel in the
first black box
and then this very first white pixel in
that box that would correspond to
this element up here zero and this first
element here
255. so the first thing we need to
mention
uh with regard to accessing these
elements is that numpy's are razor zero
based
and so if we just draw your attention
down here to this code we're going to
print out the cell associated with the
first column in the first row
so that would be the 0 0 pixel
and that would be this 0 right up here
and then
this next print statement is going to
print out the
pixel associated with the first row and
the 7th column
so that's a 1 two three
four five six seven but we give it an
index of six
because it's zero based so if you uh
take a look at the printout you get the
zero and 255.
so that's printing out the value of this
pixel here and this pixel here
so now let's scroll down a little bit
further and see how we actually modify
uh pixels so in this next code block
here
we're going to make a copy of the image
just so we can modify it and still
retain the original image for reference
so here we're going to modify the value
of four specific pixels and
indicated by these uh four assignments
here
from the 2 2 entry to the 3-3 entry
so that would actually correspond to the
um
third row and third column and
fourth row and fourth column those four
pixels right there so we're going to set
those to 200.
uh this could also be accomplished by um
numpy slicing notation so that would
just be
two to three comma two to three as
opposed to setting all four of these
assignments
but in either case uh if we display the
image you can see the
modified pixels here uh in the in the
matrix and then
of course um if you display the image
then you can see that these have been
set now to a
a light gray tone here in the center so
it's very simple to modify individual
pixels
and we just want to give you a brief
demonstration of that
the next topic that we're going to cover
here is cropping
so cropping is similar in some sense to
what we described above because it
involves
array indexing so let's take a look at
this example here
uh we're reading in a color image of
this boat in the water
and we're specifying of course that this
is uh to be read in as a color image
here
and we're storing that as a bgr format
and then the first thing we're going to
do is a swap the
color channels on that as we've uh
indicated before
and then display the image using
matplotlib
i am show so there's the image and now
suppose we're interested in cropping out
uh the small area around this boat so
let's say from rows
200 to 400 and columns 300 to 600
well the way that we would do that is
simply uh index into the
original array here rows 200 to 400 and
columns 300 to 600
and then reassign uh those values to
this new variable called cropped region
and if we plot that cropped region you
can see that's what we get
so cropping is a very simple and
straightforward
it's simply indexing into an existing
image
and extracting uh the region that you're
interested in
so now let's move on to the next section
which is resizing
and for this purpose we're going to use
the opencv function resize
and it takes several arguments so
there's two required arguments the first
one is the source image
and the second required argument is the
um
desired output size of the image and
then there's several
optional arguments here and specifically
fx and fy
which are scale factors which we're
going to demonstrate below
and then there's this uh interpolation
method
and we're not going to go into those
details but just know that there's
several interpolation methods that you
can select from
for example when you're resizing an
image up uh
you're having to invent new pixels and
therefore there's an interpolation
that's required
to do that so let's take a look at
an example down here in this first
method we're going to use the
scaling factors fx and fy and so
uh here's the call to the resize
function so we're passing it the cropped
image
and then for the second argument since
that's required we have to specify it
but it's okay if you specify it as none
and now that allows us to uh instead use
the scaling factors f x and f y in this
example we're just going to
set those to two so we're going to
double the size
of this cropped region and you can see
that
when we display the result that's that's
exactly what we get this is now
400 pixels high and 600 pixels wide
so now let's talk about another method
for resizing images
and this method we're going to set a
specific width and height for the image
so in this case
100 and 200 and we're going to create
this
two dimensional vector here indicating
both of those dimensions
and pass that as a second argument to
the resize function
and display the resize cropped region
and in this case we get exactly what we
asked for 100 wide and 200 high
but of course the image has been
distorted now because we didn't maintain
the original
aspect ratio of the image so that leads
us to the
last method here which is
still using this dimension vector here
but we're going to start by specifying a
width of 100
and then calculate the associated
desired height while maintaining the
aspect ratio so here we're
creating this ratio of the desired width
to the
original width of the image and then
using that factor to derive the desired
height here
and so now when we pass that revised
dimension
to the resize function you see that we
get an image here that
100 pixels wide and the appropriate
amount high
to maintain the the proper relationship
which turns out to be about 67 pixels
and then further here below we're going
to go ahead and write these images to
disk and then read them in
so this is the cropped region that's
been resized by a factor of two
and we're going to swap the channels on
that here and then write that to disk
and save it as
this file name here and then read it
back in and display it directly in the
browser
so you can see how large it is here and
then we'll also perform the same
operation on the cropped region
prior to resizing and display that and
you can see that it's half the size
as the um as the one that we resized
so uh that's all there is to resizing
it's fairly straightforward
and now we're going to move on to image
flipping
and the function we'll be using is flip
and it simply takes the image itself as
the first argument
and then a flip code which specifies how
we want to flip the image
and there's three options for that you
can flip it horizontally
vertically or in both directions and
those are simply specified by
1 0 and -1 and so let's take a look at
an example here
here we're passing in the original image
and we're making three function calls
uh corresponding to the three options
here for flipping and we're simply
displaying them down here below so this
first one here has been flipped
horizontally
this one's been flipped vertically and
this one's been flipped around uh both
axes
and then finally this is the original
here so that's all we wanted to cover in
this section and
thank you and we'll see you next time
in this video we're going to describe
for you how to annotate images
with lines circles rectangles and text
uh keep in mind that this also applies
to video frames and so that can be very
helpful as well
i sort of get started we're going to uh
read in an image here
and we've got it displayed here in the
browser and we'll be working with this
image
for the rest of the notebook but one
thing i wanted to point out is that
notice that even though this may have
been a grayscale image
we're actually reading it in as color
and we're doing that because we want to
demonstrate
annotations in color so we'll need to
have a color image to work with or a
color representation at least
and so let's proceed down to the first
section here we're going to learn about
how to draw a line on an image
the opencv functions that allow you to
annotate images are all very
straightforward
and in this case the first argument here
is the image itself
and then the next two arguments are the
first point and last point of the line
and then the color so those are the four
required arguments and then there's some
optional arguments that we'll
specifically take a look at as well
including thickness and line type
so let's scroll down here to the first
example
so here we're making a copy of the image
simply so we can preserve the
original image and then annotate a copy
so this one's called image line
and we're going to draw a line on this
image and you can already see it's a
yellow line
and we're going to draw it from 0.1 to
0.2
so that's 200 along the x-axis and 100
along the y-axis
that's this point here and then 400
along the x-axis
and 100 along the y-axis so that's this
point here
and then we're going to specify yellow
and recall that this
has to be in bgr not rgb and that's the
reason that
the last two channels here are 255 to
produce yellow
from red and green and then a line
thickness of five and then for the line
type we're using uh
this line underscore aaa which stands
for anti-aliased
and uh that's usually a good choice it
uses semi-transparent pixels and often
produces a very smooth and
nice looking result so that's the first
example
the remaining examples would be very
similar to this with just
some minor variations so let's take a
look at how to
render a circle on an image in this case
we have to specify the center and radius
of the circle here
but everything else is the same in the
argument list so
scrolling down to this uh example
you see we're going to render a circle
here at the coordinate
900 500 so that's 900 along the x-axis
and 500 down and then with a radius of
100
so moving on to rectangles
again there's four required arguments
but in this case uh 0.1 and 0.2
refer to the top left corner of the
rectangle in the bottom right corner
of the rectangle but again all the other
arguments are the same
and the specifications are all the same
so
in this case we're going to uh
draw a rectangle around this launch
tower here
the upper left corner of the rectangle
is at 500 100
which you can see here and then the
lower right is 700
600 which is right here and we're going
to
specify a different color for that and
then
finally moving on to text text is a
little bit different there's obviously
some additional arguments
the first argument here is the text
string
and the next argument is the origin of
the text
and that refers to the bottom left
corner
of the text string where that's going to
be placed on the image
and then the font face you might also
think of that as the
font style and then font scale is is a
floating
point number that scales the font size
and then again we have some optional
arguments here
so um just taking a look at this example
here
we're setting several of the arguments
right here so the text string is here
we're setting a font scale of 2.3 the
font face
is uh font hersheyplane if you go to the
documentation link here
you can find out what font faces are
available and i just selected this one
and then the font color is going to be
bright green and the font thickness of
two and then i've got the um origin
right here for the texturing so that's
200 700 so that's just right here at the
lower left-hand base of that text string
so that's really it annotations using
opencv
are very straightforward and simple and
that's all we wanted to cover in this
section and we'll see you next time
in this video we're going to be covering
several different basic image processing
techniques used for both image
enhancement as well as upstream
pre-processing functions that are often
used for many different applications
we'll be covering quite a few topics
including arithmetic operations
thresholding and masking and also
bit-wise operations
all of these are very fundamental to
many computer vision processing
pipelines
and we've also included a couple of
different application examples
so you can get a better feel for just
how these techniques can be used in
practice
so with that let's scroll down here and
take a look at our first example
here we're reading in a color image and
displaying it right here within the
browser
and what we'd like to do is adjust the
brightness of this image
so let's take a look at how we can do
that
so in this section here we're displaying
the original image here in the center
and then we've adjusted the brightness
of the image both
darker to the left and brighter to the
right and so let's take a look at the
code that accomplishes that
so we start here in the first line by
creating this matrix and we use the
numpy
ones method to do that and we're going
to pass in the shape of the original
image here and then also the data type
which is unsigned 8-bit
and we're going to multiply that by 50.
so now
the result of that is a matrix that's
the same size as the original image
and it's got pixel intensities of 50
everywhere in the image and so now we're
simply going to use the opencv add and
subtract functions
to uh add and subtract that matrix
from the original image and then we're
simply going to display those so that's
all that's
required to generate an image that's
darker than the original
and an image that's lighter than the
original so now let's talk about
how to change the contrast in an image
and that's a little bit different
because contrast is defined as the
difference in intensity values of the
pixels within an image
and so that's going to require a
multiplication operation
so we start here by creating two
matrices and each of these is going to
use the
numpy ones function and create a matrix
the same size as the original image and
in both cases we're going to multiply
those matrices by a factor so in this
first case it's a factor of 0.8 and in
the next case it's a factor of 1.2
so now these matrices contain floating
point values that have been scaled by
these two factors here
and on these next two lines we're going
to multiply those matrices by the
original image
but note that there's a there's a
nesting here that's required
so the two matrices we defined above
contain floating point values
so in order to multiply those by the
original image which was unsigned int
we're going to first convert those to
float and then do the multiplication
here using the opencv multiply function
and then after that we're going to
convert those back to unsigned in 8-bit
and so now we have those results here in
these two
variables and we're simply going to
display those and you can see the
results below
the original image is in the center here
the lower contrast image to the left and
the higher contrast image to the right
so you'll notice here that in the uh on
the right hand image there is this um
odd color coding in here something's
gone wrong and the reason for that is
because when we multiply the original
image by this matrix it has a factor of
1.2 in it
we potentially get values that are
greater than 255.
so if you look at the original image
here these clouds here were probably
um close to 255 some of them at least
and when we multiplied by 1.2 we
exceeded 255
so then when we attempt to convert those
values to an unsigned 8-bit number
uh rather than exceeding 255 they just
roll over
to some small number and that's why
these intensity values are now close to
zero
and so that's the reason for the issue
here so let's take a look at how do we
remedy that so if we scroll down to this
next section
and take a look at that line of code
here what we can do is use the numpy
clip function to first uh
clip those values to the range 0 to 255
before converting them to unsigned
8-bit and now when you look at the
right-hand image
it looks fine and in fact this portion
of the image here
has been completely saturated so some of
these values here
are right at 255 so they have really no
information they're the extreme
highlights within the image
so that's a summary of brightness
adjustment and also contrast adjustment
so let's continue on to the next section
of the notebook which covers image
thresholding
thresholding is a very important
technique that is often used to create
binary images that allow you to
selectively modify portions of an image
while leaving other portions intact and
we have a couple of examples below to
demonstrate this but first
i just wanted to point out a few notes
here in the documentation
i noticed that we're specifying two
different functions here
threshold and adaptive threshold so just
taking a look at the threshold function
here to see how this works
it takes as input a source image and
then a threshold value between 0 and 255
and then a max value for the binary map
and then a
type of thresholding that we're going to
perform and in all of our examples below
we're
going to be using a binary threshold so
the idea here is that whatever threshold
you specify
pixels in the original image that are
below this threshold will be set to zero
and pixels that are above that threshold
will be set to 255.
and so the result will be a binary map
that contains either zeros or intensity
values of 255
or whatever you had set the max value
here to which is typically 255.
so let's take a look at the adaptive
threshold function it also takes a
source image
a maximum value for the binary map and
then a method type to perform the
adaptive thresholding
and also a threshold type which is the
same type of input as
we had up here in the first function and
then also
a block size and a constant value here
both of these are used
by the adaptive method algorithm
basically the block size
is an indication of the pixel area
that's considered when
computing the adaptive threshold
spatially across the
image so there's a lot of detail in here
and we simply wanted to include this for
reference
and then to show you some examples below
so let's take a look at the first
example here
so here we're reading in an image which
is a photograph of a building with
lots of windows and a geometric
structure and
we're going to call the threshold
function and pass it to that image
and then give it a threshold of 100 with
a max value of 255 and then specify
this flag here to indicate that we want
a binary map
and what's returned from this function
is the
binary image this return value here is
not important at this point so
it's this argument here that contains
the actual binary
map and so we're simply going to display
that below
both the original and the thresholded
image
and you can see that there's an
opportunity here for you to
use this map as a way to selectively
process certain parts of the image so
let's take a look at a more concrete
example
down here below
suppose you were interested in building
an application that could
read and decode sheet music which is
very similar to
optical character recognition where the
goal is to recognize characters in
text documents in this case you'd be
trying to recognize musical notes
for the purpose of digitizing that
information
so in the example below it's easiest to
actually start off with talking about
these two images here and then we'll
come back up and and talk about the code
so over here on the left is the original
uh photograph of some sheet music and
you can see that it's
kind of dark here in the lower right
hand corner clearly not a white
background
but the notes are fairly well defined
they're all very dark black
which looks good and the idea here is
that we'd like to perform
thresholding on this image to achieve a
binary map
similar to the one shown here to the
right so
just taking a look at the dark values of
all these notes in the musical notation
it looks like perhaps the intensity
values of all these black areas might be
below 50 for example
they all look pretty black even some of
these up in here
look fairly black so if we create a
binary map with a threshold of 50
we're hoping that we would be able to
isolate all this important information
and the image to the right here was
actually produced with a threshold of 50
and the result is rather surprising
because notice that there's no
information up here in the top portion
of the image
that would mean that the intensity
values of all these black notes are
actually above 50
which isn't very intuitive because they
look rather dark
so that's just one example so let's go
back up here and take a look at the code
that produces these plots so here we're
just reading in the um
the original image here and then we're
going to call the threshold function
passing at the original image
a threshold of 50 a max value of 255
and then a flag here indicating that we
want to produce a binary map
and so what we get back here is the
thresholded image
and this is what is actually displayed
down here to the right
but there's some additional code here so
there's another
thresholding call here and this time
we're going to pass it a higher
threshold of 130
with the hopes that we can extract more
of this information up here in the top
of the image
and then finally we're going to call the
adaptive thresholding function
and specify the type of thresholding
algorithm
and the fact that we want to create a
binary map and then some settings here
for the algorithm
and and then we're going to display all
four of these uh below so you can see
the first two
uh here that we've already talked about
but let's scroll down here and see the
next two
so you can see that the one at the lower
left here that was produced with the
global threshold of 130 did a better job
of isolating
the musical notes here in the top
portion of the page
but that threshold was far too high in
order to
accommodate the lower portion of the
page so what's going on there is that
these
dark values on the page this shadow
essentially is actually
lower than 130. so as a result this this
whole portion of the page is just
blacked out
so neither of these global thresholds 50
or 130
do a very good job and you could
actually experiment with other
thresholds and find out that
there's not going to be a single global
threshold that's going to do
very well in this situation so notice
that the plot at the lower right here
that was produced using adaptive
thresholding is much better
this is a very good example of how you
can take an image that's
pretty challenging and has several dark
areas here and actually isolate
just about everything you want to in the
image so we simply wanted to point out
the importance of
thresholding and in particular adaptive
thresholding and so now let's move on to
the next section of the notebook
which covers bitwise operations so here
in the documentation section you can see
that we have
four different functions bitwise and or
xor
and not and here we're showing an
example of the bitwise and
it takes two input images these can
actually be the same image
but they don't have to be and then it
takes an optional mask
and the mass specifies which portion of
these two images
the logical operation applies to so
let's take a look at this uh
example down here we're reading in uh
two different images
these are both grayscale binary images
that we're going to perform these
operations on and let's
just see how that works so we'll start
with the
bitwise and operator here so in this
case
we're passing in the image of the
rectangle and the image of the circle
and then we're indicating the mask is
none so we're simply going to do a bit
wise and comparison
between these two images and the value
returned from that comparison
will be 255 or white
if the corresponding pixels in both
images are white
so in this case the result will be just
this left side of this half circle since
that's the only region
in both images where the pixels are
white so now let's take a look at the
bitwise or
um operation in this case the return
value from the operation
will be white if the corresponding pixel
from either image is white and so in
that case we get the
entire left side of the rectangle which
is white and then the
right hand side of the circle so now
let's take a look at the xor operator
and in this case we're passing at the
same set of arguments
the operation is simply different and
the exclusive or
works as follows it'll only return a
value of white
if uh either corresponding pixel is
white but not
both so this is the result that you get
here
so that's a summary of those three
functions so now let's take a look at an
application using um
bitwise operations and binary maps
so in this example here we're interested
in manipulating this
coca-cola logo and we're going to start
with the logo
and also what we call a background image
here this colorful checkerboard
and we'd like to achieve this result to
the right so essentially
being able to display a background image
behind
the white lettering and have it show
through so that's the goal and we're
going to go ahead and proceed through
this notebook
to see how that's done so first down
here we're going to read in what we call
the foreground image which is the
coca-cola logo
itself and we're going to display that
in the browser here
and then further down here we're going
to do the same thing with the
background image in this case there's a
little bit of extra code up here in
order to
make sure that that image is the exact
same size
as the coca-cola logo so as we've seen
before in a previous video
we're making use of the opencv resize
function here
to accomplish that so now we're going to
go ahead and
create a couple of masks from the
coca-cola
logo so in this top portion here we're
going to
pass in the logo here to cvt color
convert it to gray
and then use the opencv threshold
function
to create a binary mask from this
grayscale image
and we're going to call that image
underscore mask and we're displaying
that down here so this is only going to
contain values of 0 and 255.
and then we're going to perform a
similar operation down here
but not using the threshold function
although we could have we could have
used the threshold function down here
and specified a threshold binary inverse
mask
but instead we can just simply call the
bitwise not function
on the image mask to return the inverse
mask
and so you see both of these masks
displayed here in the browser now we're
going to make use of those
down here below
so now in this section we're going to do
a bit wise and
on the background image with itself but
using the image mask
so this bitwise and operation is going
to perform a bit wise in between
the corresponding pixels between these
two images which is the same image
but it's only going to apply it
to the mask which is the white lettering
in this case
and so that's the result we get
everything else is going to be zero
and we're going to get just the colors
showing through in the logo
and then we need to do a similar
operation on on the um
on the logo itself which is image
underscore rgb
and we're going to do a bit wise and
operation on
on that and pass it the inverse mask and
that's going to allow us to
only show the the red foreground
and everything else is going to be black
and so now you can see that if you just
added these two images together
the blacks sum to zero and what you get
is
the following result so we thought that
was an interesting
way to demonstrate how you could use
binary maps
and thresholding and logical operations
to
accomplish something like this so we
covered a lot of material in this video
and just keep in mind
that all of this is very fundamental to
many different image processing and
computer vision pipelines
and we'll continue on in this course
with a little more focus on actual
applications uh now that we have some of
this basic material under our belts so
thank you and we'll see you next time
in this video we're going to be
describing for you how to access the
camera attached to your computer system
and send that streaming video to an
output window on your display
so we have a short script here that
accomplishes that and
we'll walk through this and then we'll
go ahead and execute it so you can see
it in action
so starting on lines 35 and 36 we're
importing opencv and the systems module
both of which are required below and
then on line 38 we're specifying a
default
camera device index of zero on line 39
and 40 we're simply checking to see if
there was a command line specification
to override that
default value but in this case we're
just going to use zero
and then on line 42 we're going to call
the video capture
class to create a video capture object
and we pass in
device index into that class so device
index of zero
will access the default camera on your
system
if you had more than one camera attached
to your system then you would need to
indicate a device index
that points to the correct one so zero
would be the default
one would be the second camera two would
be the third camera and so forth
on line 44 and 45 we're creating a named
window which we're going to eventually
send the streamed output to
and then finally on line going to create
a while loop
and this while loop is going to allow us
to continuously stream video from the
camera and send it to the output
unless the user hits the escape key so
that's what this weight key function
does it continuously checks
whether or not the users hit the escape
key so
the first line in this loop line 48 uses
that
video capture object source to call the
read method
in that class and that read method will
return
a single frame from the video stream as
well as a logical variable
uh has underscore frame so if there's
any kind of a problem
with reading the video stream or
accessing the camera
then has frame would be false and
we would break from the loop otherwise
we'd continue on
and call the im show function in opencv
to actually send the video frame to the
output window
so that's all there is to it there's not
much code we just wanted to walk through
that and give you an example of how to
do this
so let's go ahead and execute it
and there it is here's the window
streaming video from my web camera right
to the display
as soon as i hit the escape key this is
going to uh exit
and uh that's all we really wanted to
cover in this video in the next
video we're going to uh build on this
little bit and
do some processing of the video frame
from the camera and then send the
post-processed output to the display so
that's going to be a little bit more
interesting to take a look at
so that's it for now and we'll see you
next time
in this section we're going to describe
for you how you can save videos to disc
in a previous video we described how you
can send the streaming output from your
webcam to the output display
but here we wanted to cover how you can
actually write that to disk
so we're going to start by specifying a
source here this could have been the
webcam
but here in this example we're going to
specify a file from disk
and read it in by creating a video
capture object here
and so here we're specifying uh as the
input argument to this the
source for the video file so this is our
video capture object here
and in this next section we're just
going to simply check that that was
successful
and then scrolling down here a little
bit we're going to use the read method
from that class to retrieve the first
frame of the video
and then use uh i am show to display
that in the browser so that's the first
frame of the video
and we can actually load the video here
in the browser as well
with this command here and we've already
executed that so i'll go ahead and play
it just so you can see it
it's just a very short clip of a race
car
okay so then down here we're going to
talk a little bit about
the video writer function in opencv
so this um this function allows you to
create a video file on disk and it takes
his argument the file name
and then this 4cc argument and that
stands for four
character code that describes the codec
that's used to compress the video frames
and then uh there's also the frames per
second and then the frame size
now the frame size is important because
um that needs to be the dimensions of
the frames that you have in memory that
you want to write to disk
so we'll see an example of that below so
let's
take a look at this next code section
here the very first thing we're going to
do
is use the video capture object to call
this get method which is going to
retrieve for us
the dimensions of the video frame that
we have in memory
and then now we're going to create two
video writer objects
one for an avi format and one for an mp4
format
so you can see here in both cases we're
specifying the file name
and then the 4cc codec and to do that
we're going to use this
video writer underscore 4cc function
here
and for an avi file you need to specify
these specific arguments
and for an mp4 file you need to specify
it just like this
so you can take a look at the
documentation and read up on this but
this is sort of the tricky thing
associated with writing video
files getting this codec right
and then also making sure that the frame
dimensions
match the frame size that you're trying
to
write to disk so let's now take a look
at how we actually do this
we're going to create a while loop here
and
we're going to use the read method from
this video capture object to read every
frame from the video file
and then we're simply going to pass that
frame back out to those video writer
objects that we just created up above
one for
the avi format and one for the mp4
format
and then when that's done processing
we're simply going to release the
resources down here
so that's all there is to it but we did
want to point out that
getting these codecs correct and making
sure that the
frame dimensions match the frame
dimensions of the video frames that you
have in memory
are the two key things that you need to
watch out for
so that's all we wanted to cover in this
section and uh thanks so much and we'll
see you next time
in this video we'll be demonstrating
some of the more common image processing
techniques that are often used in
computer vision pipelines
and to do this we're going to build on
the camera demonstration from the last
video where we sent streaming video from
the camera to an
output window in the display however
this time we'll be doing some image
processing on the video frames first and
then send those results to the output
display
so we hope you find this informative and
to get started we'll first take a look
at the code and then
execute it so we can talk more in depth
about the various processing techniques
and their associated parameter settings
so starting on line
39 we're defining the four different run
modes for the script which include a
preview mode
a blurring filter a corner feature
detector and a canny edge detector
then on line 44 we're defining a small
dictionary of parameter settings for the
corner feature detector
and those include the maximum number of
corners
that the algorithm will return quality
level
is a parameter for characterizing the
minimum acceptable quality of image
corners
and the way that works is that the
corner feature with the highest value in
the entire image is multiplied by this
parameter
and then that value is used as a minimum
threshold for filtering corner features
from the final list that's returned by
the algorithm so for example if you had
several features
that were detected and the maximum value
of those features was 100
then we'd multiply 100 by 0.2 which
would be 20 and then 20 would be the
threshold
for determining whether or not a a
feature corner was detected
and then the the next parameter here the
minimum distance this is the minimum
distance between adjacent uh
feature corners and this is measured in
pixel space so it's the euclidean
distance in pixel space
which describes how close two corner
features can be in the
list that's returned from the algorithm
and then finally block
size is the size of the pixel
neighborhood that is used in the
algorithm for computing uh the feature
corners
so this next block of code started on
line 48 is very similar to the code in
the previous video where we're setting
the
device index for the camera creating an
output window for the uh
streamed results and then creating a
video capture object so that we can
process the video stream in the loop
below
so here on line 61 we enter a while loop
and uh first line in that loop is to
read a frame from the video stream and
then on line 66
i'm going to flip that frame
horizontally
mainly as a convenience for myself so
that it's easier for me to point things
out
in the video stream and then here on
line 68 depending on the run
configuration
for the script we'll be executing uh one
of these
functions in opencv of course if we're
in preview mode we're simply going to
take the frame and set that to the
result and then display that directly
to the output window using im show but
for these other run modes we're going to
do some processing first and then send
the processed results to the output
window
starting on line 71 uh here we're
calling the canny edge detection
function in opencv
and the first argument there is the
image frame and then there's two
additional
arguments a lower threshold and an upper
threshold
the upper threshold is used for deciding
whether or not a series of pixels
should be considered as an edge so if
the intensity gradient of those pixels
exceeds the upper threshold then we'll
declare those pixels as constituting
a sure edge and likewise for pixels
whose intensity gradients are below the
lower threshold and those segments will
be completely
discarded however for the pixels whose
gradients fall in between these two
thresholds we'll consider those as
candidate edges if
they can be associated with a nearby
segment that has already been declared
as an edge
so in other words we're allowing for
weaker edges to be connected to stronger
ones if the weaker edges are likely to
be along the same true edge
and we'll see an example of that when we
run the demo for edge detection
uh in just a little bit then the next
function here
is a blur function in opencv and
this blur function uses a box filter to
blur the image
so the first input to this function is
the image frame itself and then this
second input are the dimensions for the
box kernel
so this would be a 13 by 13 box kernel
that would be convolved with the image
to result in a blurred image so if the
size of the kernel is smaller than the
blurring is less and if the size of the
kernel is larger then you get
more substantial blurring and then
finally
for the corner feature detector
converting the frame
uh the image frame to a grayscale image
and then on line 77 we're going to call
the function good features to track
and although it isn't indicated in the
name of this function
what this function does is compute
corner features
so the first argument is a grayscale
image of the
video frame and then the second argument
is that
dictionary of feature parameters that we
described up above
and so what that returns is a list of
corners
that were detected in the image and if
we have
one or more corners detected then we're
going to simply annotate
the result with small green circles to
indicate the locations of those features
and then after we're done with all this
whatever result we have under whatever
run mode we've been working with we're
going to send that
to the output stream so this next block
of code here is simply monitoring the
keyboard for user input
the script was written so that the run
modes could be toggled interactively
so for example if you were running in
preview mode and you wanted to
transition to candy detection mode you
would simply type a c on the keyboard
so that's all there is there really
isn't very much code required to
implement this and at this point we're
ready to go ahead and execute the script
and we'll cycle through
the different run options and talk a
little bit about the
results that we see so this is the
preview mode and here we're simply
sending the video stream from the camera
to the output window and the display
so what i'd like to do next is toggle
through the other filters that we
implemented and we'll start with the
blurring filter so i'm going to type a b
on the keyboard and you can see that the
image has been slightly blurred
there's a few reasons you might want to
do this for example if you had a noisy
image
you could apply a small amount of
blurring and still obtain an
aesthetically pleasing result
but more importantly in computer vision
and image processing
we often use blurring as a
pre-processing step to
performing feature extraction and the
reason for that is that
most feature extraction algorithms i use
some kind of
numerical gradient computation and
performing
numerical gradients on raw pixel data
can be a rather noisy
and not well behaved process so
smoothing the image prior to performing
gradients
uh turns out to be much more robust and
well-behaved
and so that's uh one of the primary
reasons we use blurring
in computer vision so now let's take a
look at
the next option which is the corner
feature detector
so now i've turned that mode on and you
can see
a small amount of corner features in the
image there's some here on the
microphone
there's a few around my face here and in
particular there's uh
several there in the painting of the
horses behind me
and we're going to talk a little bit
about how
these features are generated based on
the input arguments
that we selected and there were two
input arguments that we talked about in
particular one was a minimum
distance between features which is
fairly straightforward and the other one
was a
quality level of the features so first
we'll talk about
the uh minimum distance so here i've got
a textbook with uh
some where very well defined characters
on the front that have nice sharp edges
and we're detecting all kinds of corners
in those characters
you can see that um each of those
letters probably has
two maybe three uh corner features for
each character but when i move the book
much closer to the camera you'll see now
that um
there are several more corner features
associated with each character and the
reason for that is that those letters
are much larger in pixel space
so now i'm not constrained by the
minimum distance between
between the features because i've made
the letters so much larger in pixel
space
and then one other thing i'd like to
talk about is
i've drawn your attention to this
section of the book here with this
graphic image on it
if i put this very close to the camera
we're going to see that
we detect all kinds of corners
especially with the dots and that
pattern of the book there
so the reason those are jumping around
so much is that i'm having a hard time
holding the book really still but the
main point is that i
i'm getting all these detections here
now watch what happens when i
lower the book and expose the text
from the title of the book as soon as i
expose the text from the title
all the features associated with the
graphic image below have been filtered
out so let's take a look at that again i
raised the book
and i get all these features here and
now when i lower the book and expose
the title of the book all those have
been filtered out and the reason for
that is that that
quality level threshold we talked about
is based on the highest score for a
corner feature in the entire image and
because
the corner features associated with
these characters in the title of the
book
are so much stronger their feature score
is higher and therefore we're
effectively raising
the detection threshold for corner
features
so i just thought that was an
interesting example of
how that parameter is actually used and
how it can affect um
uh the algorithm uh in your particular
application
so uh uh finally let's uh go ahead and
cycle to the um
canny edge detection so uh
toggle to that mode and so now you can
see the results of edge detection here
you can see the
microphone is very well defined the
corner of my shoulder against the light
background of the wall is very well
defined
and then up here uh behind my shoulder
you see a painting of some horses
and the subject matter in that painting
is
is a partially defined but there's a lot
of broken edges
in that painting and so i thought it'd
be interesting to
talk about the threshold inputs for the
canny edge detector
and see if we can improve what that
looks like so before we do that i'm
going to make a screen snap
of this video feed just so we can have
something to compare to so i'll put this
aside
and now i'm going to edit the
threshold for the canny edge detector so
previously the lower threshold was very
close to the upper threshold so there
wasn't much opportunity for us to
find some weaker edges and connect them
to stronger edges but if i lower this to
something like 80
we now have an opportunity to consider
weaker edges that might be associated
with the stronger edges so i'm going to
go ahead and run this
and now we'll put these side by side for
a comparison
so if you take a look at the uh image
down below
you can see that again the outline of
the horses
was rather broken in some places and now
if you compare that
to the video stream up above you can see
that there's
been some improvement we're effectively
extending
the definition of these edges because
we're allowing
those edges to be connected to weaker
edges
that were in between those two
thresholds rather than discarding those
edges altogether
so i thought that was an interesting way
to demonstrate
how those inputs affect the results
obviously all these algorithms require
some experimenting and tuning and things
that will depend on your particular
application but
we hope this was a nice introduction for
you and
definitely encourage you to take a look
at the opencv documentation on these
functions and other functions
and write similar scripts like this one
here and do some experimentation so
that's all we wanted to cover in this
section and
we'll see you next time
in this video we're going to be talking
about image alignment which is also
referred to as
image registration image alignment is
used in many applications such as
building panoramic
images from multiple photos or
constructing hdr photos from multiple
images taken at different exposures
it's also used in the medical field for
comparing digital scans to highlight
small changes between
images so in this particular example
we're going to introduce the topic by
showing how we can perform document
alignment
the image on the left here is an image
of a form that's been printed out and
filled out by hand and placed on a table
and the goal here is to transform that
image
to an image on the right that would
align with the original template of the
form
and therefore make optical character
recognition
of this form a much easier task so
that's a preview of what we're going to
talk about so first let's scroll down
here a little bit
and talk about some of the theory of
transformations
so on the left here we have an original
image in the shape of a square
and one of the simplest transformations
we can make is a translation
which is simply a shifting of the pixel
coordinates in the original
image to the translated image as shown
here
and then beyond that we have euclidean
transformations which now include
rotation
but notice that the size and shape of
the original image has been preserved
and then further to the right we have a
fine transformations which encompass
euclidean transformations but also
include shear and scale changes
so now we have some distortion but
notice that parallel lines remain
parallel
and finally we have the homography which
is the most general transformation for
2d
images which allows us to transform the
original square
into an arbitrary quadrilateral and the
reason this is useful and interesting is
that it allows us to warp an image to
effectively change its perspective
so just as a more concrete example let's
scroll down to this next section where
we showed two images of the same book
taken from different perspectives
here we're interested in talking about
the homography between these two images
and specifically for the 2d plane
and each image is represented by the
front cover of the book
so if we can identify at least four
points in both images that correspond to
the same physical location on the front
cover of the book
then we can compute the homography that
relates these two images
so for example we've identified four
different points in both images that
we've color coded
that represent the same points on the
physical book and therefore
we call these points corresponding
points since they correspond to the same
physical location
but are obviously represented by a
different set of pixel coordinates in
each image
so given we have a set of points like
these we could simply call an opencv
function to compute the homography and
then apply the homography as a
transformation
to the image on the left for example to
effectively change its perspective to
look like the image on the right
i just keep in mind that four points is
a minimum required and in practice we
would want to find many more
corresponding points
uh but thankfully there are other
functions in opencv that enable us to do
just that so we'll take a look at those
details further
below in this notebook and just getting
back to the document alignment example
let's start taking a look
at the actual code
so here on lines two through three we're
just importing some required modules
and then the very next thing we're going
to do is simply read in the images of
the
template form and also the scan form so
we have those available to us
and in this next section here we're
simply displaying both of those images
so the we've got the original form here
on the left
and then the photo of the form that we
filled out on the table and
and taken a photograph of and again our
goal
is to take this image and apply
homography to it
so that it lines up with this form here
on the left
so let's see how to do that the very
first step in this process
is finding some number of key points in
both images
and there's not a lot of code here but
there's a lot going on that needs
some explanation so lines two and three
here
are simply converting uh the images that
we read into grayscale and the reason
for that
is that the the code that follows that
is performing some feature extraction on
these images only requires a great scale
representation of the image
and then there's this uh this code right
here that
is configuring an orb object from this
orb create
class so if you're not familiar with
image features and feature extraction
and computer vision
just know that various algorithms have
been invented over the years
to extract what we call features from
images
and uh the objective there is to try to
extract
meaningful information that is
contextually
um related to the uh the image itself so
typically we're looking for
edges and corners and
texture in images and we people have
been tried to invent
various ways to compactly represent that
information
so orb features are one way to do that
and they're available in opencv
so here we're going to create this orb
object and then we're going to use that
object
to detect and compute key points and
descriptors for each of the
images so let's just go over this each
of these call
each of these function calls returns a
list of key points
and a list of associated descriptors so
the key points
are interesting features in each image
that are usually associated with some
sharp edge or corner
and they're described by a set of pixel
coordinates that describe the location
of the
of the key point the size of the key
point in other words the scale of the
key point and then also
the orientation of the key point and
then there's an associated list of
descriptors for each key point and each
descriptor is actually a vector
of some information that describes the
region around the key point which
effectively acts
as a signature for that key point so
it's a
it's a vector representation of the
pixel information
around the key point and the idea here
is that
if we're looking for the same key point
in both images we can try to
use the descriptors to match them up
so let's uh let's scroll down here a bit
further and
just talk about these two displays so
we've we've calculated the
we've computed rather the um key points
and descriptors for
each image and here in these figures
we're
displaying just the key points so the
key points are the um
where all these red circles are key
points the center of the circle
is the location of the key point the
size of the circle represents the scale
of the key point and then the
the line connecting the center of the
circle to the outside of the circle
represents the orientation of the key
point
so those details um aren't terribly
important for this demonstration i just
wanted to point out that
all these red circles represent the the
key points
but associated with each of these key
points is a vector representation of the
image patch
at that key point which we're not
displaying but
it's the descriptors that are actually
used
to match up these key points so notice
that on the figure in the left there's
all these red circles here on the form
and on the figure to the right there's a
lot of red circles
in regions on the form that aren't even
located here on the left
so the list of key points for figure one
and the list of key points for figure
two
are um they're overlapping
but certainly there's probably some key
points in both images
that maybe are the same and those are
the ones that we're going to try to
try to find so that we can compute the
homography between these two
um image representations so
so that's the introduction to key points
now let's scroll down here a bit further
and talk about how we match those key
points
so the first step in this matching
process is to create a matcher object
by calling this descriptor matcher
underscore create function
and we pass to that function some
configurations that indicate the type of
matching algorithm we're going to use
which is brute force and then also
the metric for computing the distance
between the descriptors
which is a hamming metric a distance
measure
and that's because the descriptors for
uh orb are binary strings so we
therefore require a hamming
uh metric for that purpose and then uh
so we use that matcher object to call
the match function
which then attempts to provide a list of
the
best matches associated with those list
of descriptors and so now we
get a data structure back here that
contains the list of matches
from the key points that we determined
up above
and then once we get that list we're
going to sort the list based on the
distance
between the various descriptors and then
on lines 9 and 10 here we're going to
further
limit that to the top 10 percent of the
matches returned by
the matching function here
and we're going to use that now to draw
the matches in this code below
shown here in the image so uh we're
calling this draw matches function
and we're going to pass in the key
points for image one as well as
the image and the same for image two as
well as this
filtered list of matches computed above
and if you uh take a look at these two
images you can see that
several key points in this image match
the key points in this image for example
on
in the form over here there's a little
image of a person and further down here
it looks like an image of a house
and you can see that there were several
key points in both images
that were in that local region and then
this matching function determined that
yes there were several
here on this form that matched this form
in other words the descriptors
matched close enough for us to call that
a match
and so now we have a set of
corresponding key points right
but notice here for example right down
here this lavender line
is going up to some other location on
the form to the right so that's
that's not a match but it turned out
that the descriptor
for the key point here and the
descriptor for this key point here were
very close coincidentally
and so it decided that that was a match
it's okay to have some false positives
here the important thing is that we have
an overwhelming number
of actual matches which will allow us to
compute
a homography so then the final a couple
of steps here
in the notebook are to first compute the
homography
so to do that we simply call this find
homography function here
and pass it both sets of key points that
have been filtered
by the matching process above and then
there's an optional
argument here which is the algorithm
that's going to be used
to compute the homography and here we're
indicating the
ransack algorithm which is definitely
the one you want to use
that's very robust to filtering out
outliers
left over from the matching process
computed above
and there's a little bit of code up here
that requires us to change the format of
the points so that um to comply with the
uh
this fine homography function but that's
um that's a detail that the point here
is that we can
compute the homography from a set of uh
corresponding key points
and then finally once we have uh the
homography
h which is a three by three matrix we
can
uh call this uh function warp
perspective
on image two and recall image two was
the image of the filled out form sitting
there on the table
and passing the homography and what we
get back
is the registered or aligned
image as shown below here to the right
so now we've
we've effectively changed the
perspective of that image on the table
and it's very closely aligned to the
image on the form here
and now this is obviously a much simpler
task
to process uh you know automatically
process this form on the right
this form on the right can be compared
to the form on the left
and an algorithm could be written to it
knows where the last name field is on
the form so then
it can easily recognize uh
these characters here as the last name
of the person that has filled out the
form
so that's one example of how you can use
image alignment or image registration
and there's many other applications as
we mentioned earlier so
you can see in very few lines of code
you can get this up and running
you can experiment with your own images
and that's a lot of fun to do so and we
encourage you to
explore that more so we hope this was
helpful to you and we'll see you next
time
in this video we're going to be
describing how you can create panoramas
from multiple
images using opencv much of the
processing pipeline used for creating
panoramas is very similar to the steps
we described in the image alignment
video since panoramas require image
alignment we still need to find key
points and descriptors in each of the
images
and also determine their pairwise
correspondences
through a feature matching process and
we also need to estimate the
homographies
to facilitate image warping and then
once
images have been transformed in this way
we need an additional step to stitch and
blend the images
together so they look realistic and
fortunately there's a high level
convenience function in opencv that's
available in the stitcher class that
allows us to create panoramas by simply
passing in
a list of images however we do think
it's important to understand the
underlying concepts but since we covered
much of this
material in great detail in the image
alignment video
we're simply going to use the stitcher
class in this example
to show you just how easy it is to
create panoramas with a single function
call
i just remember that images used to
create panoramas need to be taken
from the same vantage point ideally on a
tripod that is panning around the
optical axis of the camera and it's also
important to take the photos at roughly
the same time in order to minimize any
lighting changes between the images
so adhering to these suggestions will
lead to the best results
so let's get started and take a look at
the code that's required
here in this first cell block we're
importing some required modules
and then in this next code section we're
using glob
to retrieve the file names from a
subdirectory
and then in this for loop here we're
simply reading in
each of the file names and converting
the images from
bgr to rgb and then appending
each image to a list of images and then
in this next section here
we're simply plotting each of the images
so you can see the sequence here there's
six images total
and then finally in the last section
here you can see that we're going to be
able to create the panorama in just two
lines of
code so we do that by creating a
stitcher object from the stitcher
underscore create class and then we use
that object to call the stitch method
and we simply pass in the list of images
and
the result we get here is the panorama
image
so that's shown below uh the only thing
we would mention at this point is that
the return panorama includes these black
regions here which are a result of the
warping that was required to stitch the
images together
and we'd just like to mention that maybe
one thing you might consider doing is
writing your own code
to programmatically crop out that black
image
you could use a combination of
thresholding techniques uh bitmaps and
contour finding uh to do that task so
that's all we really wanted to cover in
this section and uh thanks so much and
we'll see you next time
hi everyone in this video we're going to
be talking about high dynamic range
imaging also referred to as hdr imaging
and i think the best way to get started
with this is to just take a look at the
simple example below here we have two
photos of a young boy
this photo below on the left was taken
with an iphone
in standard camera mode and in that case
the metering system on the camera
attempts to determine what the main
subject matter of the photo is in this
case the young boy
and then it tries to set the exposure
accordingly so it's done a nice job here
the boy is properly exposed yet the
background the sky and the clouds are
completely washed out
and then sometimes the opposite occurs
sometimes you'll get a background that's
properly exposed yet the
the foreground is just far too dark and
the reason this occurs is because the
actual intensities in the real world
scene far exceed the capability of the
camera to record those values
since most cameras only have an 8 bit
per channel
capability there just aren't enough bits
to capture the full
dynamic range of the scene so in
contrast to that
we have the image to the right this
image was also taken with an iphone in
hdr mode and in this case both the
foreground and the background are all
properly exposed and the photo looks
fantastic so how exactly is this done
well what the iphone does is it takes
three photographs at different exposures
and it takes them in quick succession so
that there's no movement
uh or almost no movement in between the
three shots
and then it takes those uh three what we
call
low dynamic range photos and merges them
to come up with a
hdr photo like the one shown here so
that's the basic idea
and we'll talk about this in a little
more detail
down here below with a different example
so this is a common uh photo sequence of
the old courthouse in st
louis that's used to describe hdr
imaging
you can see that there's four different
images here taken at different exposures
the image to the far left uh
underexposed quite a bit although that
there is some
area here in the lower portion of the
building that looks properly exposed and
might contain some useful detail
and then further to the right here
there's a little bit more
of the building that's properly exposed
still the center is nice too and then
these other areas here
might provide useful information and
then even further to the right here now
the buildings in the background
start to have proper exposure and then
finally to the right uh the well-lit
portion here in the center is completely
blown out
but perhaps the um the background
buildings and even the sky for example
and then some of these areas in the
foreground uh might contain useful
information so the hope is that
collectively this sequence of four
images
across all pixels in the image will
contain some useful information that can
be
merged together to form a single hdr
image
with proper exposure for all of the
pixels
so let's take a look at some of the code
that implements this
example down here we're just importing
some required modules
and then right here we're defining a
convenience function that's going to
read the images and the exposure times
for each image
so in here we're just listing the file
names of the four images
and right down here we're setting the
exposure times for each of those images
we know what that is for this example
but you could also
extract that information from the
metadata in each image and do that
programmatically
and then finally down here in this for
loop we're just reading each of the
images in and converting them to rgb
and then returning the list of images
and the exposure times
so the next step in the process uh once
we've read in the images
is to make sure they're properly aligned
and even though these images may have
been taken in quick succession or even
on a tripod in quick succession
it's important that they be very
accurately aligned
down to the pixel level or even the sub
pixel level
so just as an example the image here to
the left is an hdr
image that was produced without
alignment and you can see that the
zoomed in section here at the top of the
building has several ghosting artifacts
and just doesn't look
quite right and it's not a true
representation of that portion of the
image
now contrast that with the hdr image
produced on the right
this was produced with alignment and you
can see that the top portion of the
building
looks much more correct however since
the images that are used in the sequence
are taken at different exposures they
actually look different
and therefore standard alignment
techniques just don't work
however there is a special class in
opencv that uses bitmaps
for this purpose and that class is
called
create a line mtb for median threshold
bitmap
so down here we're going to create an
align mtb object
and then use that object to call the
process method from that class
and pass at the list of images and then
get back the list of
aligned images right here so once we've
done the alignment
of the images the next step in the
process
is to compute the camera response
function and the reason we need to do
this
is because most cameras we use are not
linear which means for example that if
the radiance in a scene is doubled the
pixel intensities recorded by the camera
will not necessarily double
and this presents a problem when we want
to merge images taken at different
exposures
so for example suppose the response
function was linear then the intensities
of the input images could be simply
scaled by their exposure times
which would put them on the same radian
scale and then we could simply compute
an average intensity at every pixel
location
across those images to synthesize an hdr
image
however since the response function is
not linear we need to estimate it so
that we can first linearize the images
before combining them
however since the response function for
various cameras are considered
proprietary information by the camera
manufacturers we need to actually use
the images
captured by the camera itself to
estimate the response function
and this is actually a rather involved
optimization problem but
fortunately opencv has two different
classes that we can use for this purpose
both named after the people that
invented the algorithms
so let's take a look at the code uh in
opencv that accomplishes this
uh the one we're going to be focusing on
is create calibrate debevic
there's another one by robertson in
either case
there's a class for each algorithm and
here we're creating a
calibrate devic object and then we're
using that object to call the process
method for that class
and we pass in the list of images and
the
associated exposure times for those
images and we get back
the inverse camera response function
here and so this next block of code here
is simply plotting the camera response
function
and you can see at the lower intensity
values the function is quite linear
in this region here and then starts to
become non-linear
right about here and then finally at the
higher end of the spectrum
we start to see some clipping at 255 as
the
intensities in the actual scene exceed
the recording limits of the camera
also notice that the three channels are
calibrated separately since
the sensitivities are slightly different
between them
and so now we can use this function to
linearize the input images by mapping
the measured pixel intensity in those
images to the calibrated intensity
so that the images can then be merged
appropriately so in this next section
here
we use a separate class for that purpose
here we're calling the create mergedabit
class to create an object
and then using that object to call the
process method in that class
passing at the list of images the
exposure times for each of the images
and then the response function that we
calculated up above
and that method then returns the hdr
image that we've been looking for so at
this point it's worth
mentioning that the merging process
intentionally ignores pixel values close
to zero or 255
and the reason for that is that pixel
values close to those extremes contain
no useful information so it's common
to apply a hat type weighting function
to each of the input images to filter
out those pixels
from the merging process so just to
briefly summarize
because there are multiple images of the
scene at different exposure settings the
hope is that
for every pixel we have at least one
image that contains an
intensity that is neither too dark nor
too bright
however there is one problem that still
remains which is the intensity values
are no longer
in the zero to 255 range of course black
is completely zero but hdr images can
record light intensities from zero to
essentially infinite brightness
so because they have a fixed range they
need to be stored as 32-bit floating
point numbers
and since our displays require 8-bit
images we need one last step to bring
the image intensities back down to the
0-255 range
so that brings us to the final step in
the process which is called tone mapping
which refers to the process of mapping
hdr images to 8-bit per channel
images so there's several algorithms
implemented
in opencv for this purpose mostly
designed to preserve as much detail as
possible from the original image
while converting it to 8 bits per
channel but the main thing to keep in
mind is that there's no correct way to
perform tone mapping
sometimes the goal of tone mapping is to
achieve an aesthetically pleasing image
that isn't necessarily realistic however
the algorithms implemented in opencv
tend to be fairly realistic yet they
have
some differences and also various
parameters that are configurable
for each of the algorithms so in this
first example we're going to take a look
at using drago's method
to create a tone map and we start by
calling the create tonemapdrago
class and to create an object and then
use that object to call the process
method for that class and we simply pass
it the hdr
image itself and that returns the 8-bit
per channel color image
shown below here it does a very nice job
of
properly exposing all regions of the
scene there it's very pleasing in my
opinion
and even the background the buildings
there seem to be properly exposed
so very nice result and then moving on
to the next example
this one is using reinhardt's method and
it also looks very nice perhaps not as
ascetically pleasing but certainly very
realistic
and with everything properly exposed
and then finally there's one more
example down here that's almost a
combination
of the two i'd say a little bit of the
glowing here and in the center like the
first image
and again everything uh looking fairly
realistic and
and properly exposed so that's a summary
of the
hdr imaging process we covered a lot of
detail but when you step back and look
at how much
code was required it wasn't very much so
that's all we really wanted to cover in
this section
and we'll see you next time thank you
in this video we're going to be talking
about object tracking this is a really
interesting topic and a lot of fun
to experiment with and we hope you enjoy
this demonstration
so first of all what is tracking
tracking usually refers to
estimating the location of an object and
predicting its location at some future
point in time
and in the context of computer vision
that usually amounts to
detecting an object of interest in a
video frame and then predicting
the location of that object in
subsequent video frames
and we accomplish this by developing
both a motion model
and an appearance model the motion model
for example will estimate the position
and velocity
of a particular object and then use that
information to predict its location in
future
video frames and then we can also use an
appearance model which encodes what the
object looks like
and then search the region around the
predicted location from the motion model
to then fine
tune the location of the object so the
motion model is an approximation
to where the object might be located in
a future video frame and then the
appearance model
is used to fine-tune that estimate all
of the
code that we'll be using below is from
the opencv api
tracker class so we'll talk about that a
little bit more as we
scroll down through the notebook here so
as a concrete example suppose we're
interested
in tracking a specific object like the
race car identified here in the first
frame of a video clip
in order to initiate the tracking
algorithm we need to specify the initial
location of the object
and to do this we define a bounding box
shown here in blue which consists of two
sets of pixel coordinates
which define the upper left and lower
right corners of the bounding box
and then once the tracking algorithm is
initialized with this information
the goal is to then track the object in
subsequent video frames by producing
a bounding box in each new video frame
so
we'll talk more about this below but
before we get started uh with the code
description let's just take a look at
the
tracking algorithms available in opencv
there's uh eight different algorithms
listed here
and we're not going to review the the
details of each of these
but it's worth noting that depending on
your application
one might be more suitable than the
other for example
some are more accurate some are faster
some are more robust to occlusions of
the object being tracked
so that's worth keeping in mind when you
experiment with all of these uh
different algorithms
and then one other thing that's worth
mentioning is that the go
turn model uh here is the only one
that's deep learning based
and we'll talk a little bit more about
that further below
so uh just as a preview to get started
here i've got the um
uh the test video clip right here and
let's just play it uh one or two times
so you'll notice that early on the car's
appearance is relatively constant as
well as its
uniform motion but as it starts to make
a turn here you'll see that
we see the broadside portion of the car
and then the lighting is starting to
change quite a bit
and then now it's getting smaller and
smaller off into the distance
so those types of things are going to
represent some challenges
uh for some of the tracking algorithms
so we'll talk a little bit more about
that
so let's start taking a look at the
first code block in this notebook
here we're just importing some modules
that are required and then on line 10
we're indicating the file name for the
video clip that we're going to process
and then here we're defining
some convenience functions that will
allow us to render bounding box
information on the output video stream
as well as annotate the output video
frames with some text
and then recall earlier we described
that one of the
algorithms is the go turn model which
requires an inference model
so this block of code here is
required to download that inference
model and then
this figure here is a very high level
description of
uh how the go turn tracker is trained
and used
so in the center here we're indicating
that we have a pre-trained
neural network model also known as an
inference model
and it takes as input two cropped images
one from the previous frame and one from
the current frame
uh it uses the bounding box from the
previous frame to crop
both of these images and therefore the
object of interest
uh is located in the center of this
previous frame
and obviously if the object has moved um
in the current frame then it won't be
centered uh in this cropped image
because we're using the bounding box
from the previous frame to crop both of
these images
and then uh it's the job of the
inference model to then predict
uh what the bounding box is uh in the
output frame here
so that's just a high level description
of how that works
so let's scroll down a bit further here
and take a look at this next code block
this is where we're going to create a
tracker instance
and we start by defining a list of
tracker types here where we're just
indicating
the list of string names that are
available in the opencv api
and then depending on the track or
algorithm that you wanted to execute you
would just set the appropriate index
here into that list and since that's
specified as two
then we'd be indicating that we'd like
to execute the kcf
tracker in that list and this uh if else
block here would then
call the appropriate class to create the
tracker object so in the case of
uh the default we'd be calling the
tracker kcf underscore create class to
create a tracker object of that class
so let's scroll down here to the next
section uh
in this block of code uh we're setting
up the input output
video streams so here on line two we're
passing in the
video input file name and creating a
video input object and then on the next
line we'll go ahead and read the first
frame from that video file
and then down here on lines 13 and 14
we're doing a similar thing for the
output video stream
and creating a video out object which
will then
write results to from our tracking
algorithms
now in this section here as we talked
about earlier we need to define a
bounding box
around the object that we're interested
in tracking and
we're accomplishing that here just
manually notice that i'm specifying the
two sets of pixel coordinates here for
the upper left and lower right corners
of that bounding box
but in practice you would um either
select that with a user interface or
um or perhaps uh use the detection
algorithm to
detect objects of interest for tracking
and
do that programmatically uh so but for
demonstration purposes here we're just
going to
set that box manually and then down here
we're now ready to initialize the
tracker
so in order to do that we use the
tracker object here and call the init
function
and we pass it the first frame of the
video clip
and then the bounding box uh that we
defined manually up above
okay and then once that's defined we're
ready to enter
a loop here to process all the frames in
the video so this first line of code
in the loop on line 2 is reading the
next frame
from the video clip and then on line 10
here we're going to pass that frame to
the tracker update function
and hopefully return a bounding box for
the object
that was detected so if we detect the
object and we retrieve a bounding box
from the update function
uh then we'll go ahead and render a
bounding box
rectangle on the current frame and if we
didn't detect
the bounding box and this okay flag
would be
false and we'd simply annotate the frame
with a tracking failure
message indicated here and then
further below we'll also annotate uh the
video frame
with the type of tracker that's being
used and the frames per second that's
been calculated
and then write that frame out to the
output video stream so that's all this
loop does it
um cycles through each frame in the
video clip
and calls the tracker update function
and then annotates the frames and sends
them to the output video stream
so let's scroll down here a bit further
and take a look at some results so this
notebook has already been executed
a few times for different trackers and
so we're now we're just going to replay
those results so
all of these results shown here are the
output video streams that have been
annotated with tracker results
and you can see in this first example
this is the kfc tracker
and i'm going to go ahead and play this
and we'll take a look at how it performs
so it looks like it's doing a fairly
good job of tracking the car
a little bit off-center but uh still
maintaining track on what's
um obviously the car in the video frame
and then as the car rounds the corner
it's uh it's doing okay
and then uh shortly here we're gonna see
that uh has a little bit of difficulty
right here at the end it drops track on
the car
uh so let's take a look at the next
example the next example here is the
csrt tracker and we'll go ahead and take
a look at that
so this one does a little better job
tracking the car
with the bounding box encompassing most
of the car
and centered on the car pretty much and
then as the car
makes the turn here uh the box is on the
front of the car but it's still got the
car and track
i'd say and then right there at the end
it looks like it's having difficulty
maintaining a precise location for the
car
so let's go down to the the final
example and this is the go
turn tracker again trained on a
deep neural network offline so let's
take a look at this
so it looks like it's maintaining track
as well the bounding box is a little
narrower but centroid it on the on the
car
and then as it rounds the corner here it
still maintains uh
track the car is pretty much in the
center of that bounding box
uh for the most part it gets a little
wider there but then as it tails off it
uh
it maintains uh track on the car right
there at the end
so out of the three examples of the go
turn tracker probably uh did the best
job of maintaining track
uh throughout the entire video uh stream
and especially right there at the end
still able to keep the car essentially
in the centroid of that bounding box
so we hope that gives you a good feel
for how to exercise the various tracking
algorithms in opencv
and especially the small amount of code
that's required in order to get
something up and running
so we encourage you to experiment
further try some of your own videos
and experiment with the various
algorithms and we hope this was helpful
to you and we'll see you next time
in this section we're going to show you
how you can use a pre-trained neural
network to perform face detection
and to do that we're going to be using
the opencv framework that will allow us
to read in a pre-trained model and
perform
inference using that model so to get
started
there's a little bit of code here at the
top of the script that sets the device
index for the camera
creates a video capture object and then
creates an output window for sending all
the results to the display
however since we've covered this in a
prior video we're going to skip
that discussion and focus our attention
here on line
47. so opencv has several convenience
functions that allow us to read in
pre-trained models that were trained
using
various frameworks so for example caffe
tensorflow
dark net and pytorch are all deep
learning frameworks that allow you to
design and train neural networks
and thankfully opencv has built-in
functionality to use pre-trained
networks to perform
inference so just to be clear you cannot
use opencv to train a neural network but
you can use it to perform inference on a
pre-trained network
and that's very nice for getting
familiar with using neural networks and
getting started
so this function read net from caffe
is a function that's specifically
designed to read in a cafe model
and it takes two arguments the first
argument here is the prototext file
which contains the
network architecture information and
then the next file is the caffe model
file and that's a much larger file that
contains the weights
of the model that's been trained so
notice here that we're pointing to these
files on our local system
however they can also be downloaded from
the internet so let's take a look at the
um
the get repo that contains these models
so here in this repo there's several
scripts at this level
and if you scroll down a bit uh you'll
see that there's a download models
script right here and if scroll down a
little bit further you'll see that
there's a readme file here
that contains a description and
instructions on how to use that script
to download various models
so it turns out that that script
actually references a
models.yaml file which is right here and
it's instructive to go ahead and take a
look at
that so at the top of that file you'll
see a block here
that references the caffe model that
we're actually going to be using
here is the url to download the weights
file
and then there's several other
parameters here
related to how that model was trained
and so we'll talk about these in a
minute because we're going to reference
these values in our script but just
notice that there's a mean
value a scale factor a height and width
and also this rgb flag
so let's go back to the script and
continue on
when we call this read net from cafe
method
it returns for us an instance of the
network and we're going to use that
object further below to perform
inference on our test images from the
video stream
so this next section here is identifying
the model parameters that were
associated with how the model was
trained
and it's important that we're aware of
these because
any images that we pass through the
model to perform inference on
also need to be processed in the same
way that the training images were
processed so here we have the size of
the input images that were used to train
the model
300 by 300 and then here we have a list
of mean values
from each of the color channels across
all the images that were used
in training and then this confidence
threshold
is a value that you can set that will
determine the sensitivity of your
detections
so then scrolling down here a bit
further we enter this while loop
and the first thing we do in the loop is
read one frame at a time from the video
feed
and on line 59 i'm going to flip that
frame horizontally just as a convenience
for myself so that when i point to
things in the
field of view of the camera it's easier
for me to do that but it has no
consequence
other than that and then on line
60 and 61 we're simply retrieving the
size of the
video frame and then on line 64
this is important uh here we're doing
some pre-processing on the image frame
calling this method blob from image so
there are several arguments here and
we'll go through these but this
all this has to do with is doing some
pre-processing on the input image and
putting it in the proper format
so that we can then perform inference on
that image
so it takes as input the image frame
from the video stream
this next argument is the scale factor
and recall that the scale factor in that
yaml file was
one but that's not always the case when
models are trained
sometimes the images are scaled to
different ranges and if that was the
case this would have been something
other than one
then this is the input width and height
of the images so that was 300 by 300
and we've identified that up above and
then this is the mean value
which is going to be subtracted from all
the images
and then there's this flag swap rb rb
stands for red blue
notice that that's equal to faults and
the reason for that is that both cafe
and opencv use the same convention
for the three color channels but some
models use a different convention
and in those cases you'd have to swap
the red and the blue channels
and then finally there's this last input
argument crop
this last argument indicates that you
can either crop
your input image to be the correct size
or you can resize it
so because crop is set to false that
means we're going to simply resize the
image to be 300 by 300.
and then this function call then returns
a
blob representation of the input image
frame with all that pre-processing
handled and then there's
also a format change and then we pass
that blob representation of the image to
this
function set input and that prepares it
for
for inference and then this very next
line a net dot forward
makes a forward pass through the network
and is performing inference on this
representation of our input image
and then for some number of detections
returned by the inference
we're going to loop over all those
detections and
right here we're going to determine if
the confidence for particular detection
exceeds the detection threshold and if
it does
we'll proceed further and query the
detections
list for the bounding box coordinates of
that particular detection
and then the rest of the code here is um
going to render
a bounding box rectangle for the
detection
on the image frame right here and then
we're also going to
build a text string that indicates the
confidence level for the detection
and annotate the image frame
using opencv rectangle and put text
functions right here
and then once we're done processing all
the detections we'll finally
call this get performance profile
function which is going to return for us
the time required to perform inference
and we're going to convert that to
milliseconds and then build another text
string here
and continue to annotate the frame with
the amount of time that it took
to perform the inference and then
finally we're going to use im
show to display that annotated frame
to the output window so that's all there
is there isn't much
code required to perform inference on
the model and in fact
most of this code here is related to
annotating the frame itself
so at this point we're ready to go ahead
and execute the script and when we do
that we'll cycle through some
demonstrations and see just how this
performs
so here you can see the model is
detecting my face uh
very nicely and i can um obscure my face
a little bit with my hand and it still
does a nice job
of detecting my face the reason i like
using the video stream
is that it's just a lot of fun to
experiment with that you can hold up
images to the camera
and experiment with the uh scale and
orientation of the images in real time
and so we're going to do that i've got a
magazine here that i found a lot of
interesting images in and
so we'll cycle through that and we'll
see what you think so i'll scooch out of
the way here and we'll get started in
just a second
so in this first image here you can see
the boy's face is in a downward pose and
also his bangs are
obscuring his forehead and even a
portion of his eyes
yet the model still performs nicely and
detecting his face
so we thought we'd start with this image
and then progress to some that are a
little bit more difficult
in this next image here you can see the
young girl's face is also in a downward
pose but is also a profile view
and then of course she's wearing eye
glasses which may present an additional
challenge
yet the model still performs nicely
these next couple of images have a
mixture of
the face as well as some graphics
mixed in so kind of a mixed media
obscuration of the face if you will
and the model does very nicely on this
one
and here's another example on the
opposing page
and in this case notice the the
different scales of the images that are
being detected
but the model still is handling things
very nicely
so this next one coming up is my
favorite
primarily because it's the most
impressive so take a look at this
as you can see the woman's face is
heavily occluded and there's even been
some manipulation
of the image in the area around her eyes
and also
around her chin and mouth almost a
blurring to some extent
so those both represent significant
challenges yet the model is able to
detect her face fairly well and we hope
this gets you really excited about
computer vision and especially
deep neural networks just remember that
you don't have to train your own models
you can
use a pre-trained model like we've done
here in this demonstration
and write just a small amount of code to
do your own testing with your own images
so that's all we wanted to cover and we
encourage you to do that and i will see
you next time
in this section we're going to describe
how to perform deep learning based
object detection and specifically we'll
be using a neural network called single
shot multi-box detection
trained using tensorflow and like
previous videos we're going to be using
opencv to both
read the model and perform inference on
some sample test images
if you look at this name here it says
ssd which stands for single shot
multi-box detection
the single shot refers to the fact that
we're going to make a single forward
pass through the network to perform
inference and yet detect multiple
objects within an image
and like other types of networks ssd
models can be trained with different
architectural backbones
which essentially means you can model a
single concept yet use different
backbones depending on your application
so in this case we're using a mobile net
architecture which is a smaller model
intended for mobile devices
but before we get started i wanted to
point out this resource here
there's a tensorflow object detection
model zoo at this url
and if you go to that repository you can
download a variety of
different object detection models so we
just wanted you to be aware of that
in this particular case we're going to
be using the
ssd mobilenet v2 coco 2018
archive listed here and if you extract
that archive you'll see it has a
structure like the one shown here
and we simply wanted to point out that
you only need one file from that archive
and that would be the frozen inference
graph right here which is the weights
file
for the model and there's actually two
other files that we'll need to have in
order to run this notebook so let's
scroll down and take a look at those as
well
so right here we're specifying the three
models that are required
the frozen inference graph which we just
described above
and then there's a configuration file
for the network that's indicated here
with the dot pb
text extension and then also the class
labels
for the data set that was used to train
this model which is the coco 2018 data
set
you can actually google that coco data
set and retrieve this
class labels file from numerous places
on the internet
but in terms of this configuration file
there's actually a script
that you can use to generate this file
from the frozen inference graph and that
script
is indicated right here uh we've already
executed this notebook and so we have
all these files locally in our system
but we just wanted to review with you
how to obtain uh each of these three
files
and then one thing that's worth pointing
out at this point is
take a look at the class labels for this
file that we printed out down here in
the
lower portion of the screen notice the
difference between a deep learning
object detector and a traditional
computer vision
object detector we used to have a
detector for every class so for example
we had a face detector and a person
detector and so on
and those were all separate models but
with deep learning models we have
enormous capacity to learn so a single
model can detect multiple objects over a
wide range of aspect angles and scales
which is the real beauty of deep
learning so let's scroll down here a
little bit further to the next section
of the notebook
so summarize here are the three steps
that need to be performed
first loading both the model and the
input image into memory
and then detecting objects using a
forward pass through the network
and then finally displaying the detected
objects with bounding boxes and class
labels
and so the first step is indicated here
where we're calling the opencv function
read net from tensorflow
and that takes as input a model file and
the configuration
file both of which we specified above
and then that's going to return for us
an
instance of the network here which we'll
use further below to perform inference
next here we're defining a convenience
function called detect objects and it
takes as input
the network instance and then the test
image and then
we've seen this before here there's
another opencv function called blob from
image
and this takes as input the test image
and then several other arguments that
are related to pre-processing
uh the test image i recall that when we
prepare an image
for inference we need to perform any
pre-processing on that file
that was performed on the training set
and so this function contains several
arguments related to
the required pre-processing this first
argument here is a scale factor and it's
set to one
uh which indicates that the training set
didn't have any special
scaling performed on it then here we're
indicating the size of the training
images
and we're indicating that right here
with the 300 so the
test image will need to be reshaped
according to this size
and then the next argument is this mean
value if the training images
had um had a mean subtracted value
applied to them then this would have
been
some other vector but since um those
images don't require any mean
subtraction we're simply indicating
zeros here
and this next argument here uh swap rb
for
whether or not we want to swap the red
and the blue channels and then in this
case we do want to do that since the
training images used a different
convention
than what's used by opencv and then
finally
this crop flag is set to fault so that
means that the images
are simply going to be resized as
opposed to cropping them to the right
size
and then this function returns for us a
blob representation of that image that's
been pre-processed so there's a
pre-processing step and then there's
also
a format conversion step if you will
and then this blob representation of the
image is passed to the set input
method to prepare the image for uh
inference
and then finally we perform inference on
the test image by calling the forward
method
and that returns for us some number of
objects
that have been detected and then we'll
return that from this function
so there's a couple more convenience
functions down here below so let's take
a look at those
this one here display text takes in the
test image frame and then
a text string and some coordinates so
this is a function that will simply
annotate a bounding box with the class
label by drawing a black rectangle here
and then annotating the frame with some
text indicating the class label inside
the black rectangle
and then finally there's this display
objects
function and then it also takes in the
test image and then a list of objects
that were detected and then the
threshold for detection here
and here we're retrieving the shape of
the input test image
and then we're going to loop over all
the objects that were detected
by the network and retrieve their class
ids and their scores
and in this next section here we're
further going to retrieve the
coordinates for the bounding box of that
object and
convert those coordinates to the
original test image coordinates
and then finally if the score for this
object is greater than our input
threshold then we'll
go ahead and annotate the frame with the
class label i'm calling that display
text function we just described above
and then finally we're going to render
the test image frame with the bounding
box rectangle in white
right here so let's take a look at some
results
so you can see here we're reading in a
test image and
now we're going to use the function we
created above
detect objects passing at the network
instance here
and the image we just read in here and
the return from that function is a list
of objects that have been detected and
then we're going to call the display
objects function passing in the test
image and the array of objects
and you can see the result down here
there's all kinds of objects being
detected
there's a person here there's a bicycle
here there's a car here
there's cars off in the distance and
even way out in the distance here you
can see a traffic light's been detected
so this is a very robust
object detection algorithm has about 80
classes
and let's take a look at another example
down here below
this is a sports scene so you can see
the same sequence here reading in the
image
calling detect objects and then display
objects and in this case we're getting
uh
both people in the image the bat the
baseball glove which is really nice
and then uh baseball but notice that the
baseball actually has a false positive
there's only one baseball there yet the
detection algorithm is
uh reporting two so there's a false
positive there
but other than that it's done a very
nice job and
let's let's take a look at one more
example
so here's another sports scene here and
you can see it's detecting the soccer
player here
the soccer ball here and then there's a
false positive here it thinks that the
tip of his shoe
is actually another sports ball and one
thing we can do in cases like this is
after you've
established some number of false
positives you can actually take these
image examples
and perform what's called hard negative
mining by training the network with
additional examples
like this to reduce the number of false
positives
so we hope that's a nice introduction
for you to object detection and that's
all we wanted to cover in this section
and we'll see you next time
in this section we're going to show you
how you can perform 2d human pose
estimation on your own images and video
by using a pre-trained model called open
pose
open pose was developed at the carnegie
mellon perceptual computing lab
and if you're not familiar with the pose
estimation the figure below from the
open pose research paper provides a nice
graphic
so essentially the problem requires
taking an input image that may contain
one or more people
and then identifying the key points
associated with the major joints in the
human anatomy
and then logically connecting those key
points as shown in the figure
on the right hand side here the model
actually produces
two types of output part confidence maps
and part affinity maps
however for the code demonstration below
will only be using a single person in
the image
and therefore we'll only need to make
use of the confidence maps
which are also referred to as
probability maps
and we'll see how that's done further
below so just a brief history
for a long time human pose estimation
was a very difficult problem to solve
robustly
especially on some of the more
challenging benchmark cases
the reason the problem can be hard is
that joints are not always very visible
there are numerous opportunities for
occlusions of one type or another
and then clothing or other objects can
further obscure the image
and then there's the added complexity of
not only identifying key points but
associating them with the right people
if there's multiple people in the image
however once deep learning was applied
to this problem domain just a few years
ago
we really began to see dramatic
improvements and it's been really
exciting to see just how well these
models now perform
so in this demo we're going to be using
the open pose cafe model that was
trained on the multi-purpose image data
set
and we'll be doing that using a single
image which we'll get to in just a
minute but we wanted to point out that
human pose estimation is often applied
to video streams
for various applications such as
intelligent trainers for example
so we wanted to just start with some
example results on a video clip to whet
your appetite
and then we'll walk through the code for
a single image implementation but just
remember that the code can easily be
adapted
to process a video stream as we've shown
in prior videos
so just scrolling down here a little bit
to this first example
this video clip which we're going to
show was
processed using open pose and the open
pose results have been overlaid on the
video stream so let's take a look so all
three hockey players are wearing bulky
uniforms which is a challenge
and then they're also including each
other to some extent yet the model
is performing uh pretty nicely if you
just take a look at the results
it's a lot of fun to work with and
of course we'll be taking a look at a
single image example but we thought it
was instructive to show you
how exciting that is to process videos
so let's continue on and take a look at
the rest of the notebook
so in this first section here we're
simply specifying the model
here is the prototex file here and then
the
cafe model or the weights file right
here we downloaded those already and
have
already executed this notebook but there
are references in this notebook here for
where you can
download these files and then in this
next section here we're specifying the
number of points in the model
and the associated uh linkage pairs here
by their indices
so these each of these blocks here
refers to a linkage
in the human anatomy and zero starts at
the head one is the neck
two is the right shoulder three is the
right elbow and so forth
so this is a mapping that the model uses
during training and we're gonna need
this mapping to
process the output from the network
further below
and then right here on this line we're
calling the read
net from cafe we've seen that before in
a previous video
where we just pass in the prototex file
and the weights file for the trained
network
and that creates for us uh instance of
the network and we'll use that below for
inference
so now we're ready to read in our test
image and we're doing that right here
uh in this code block with imread and
then we're also
swapping the red and blue color channels
here on the next line
and then these two lines are retrieving
the size of the image which we'll use
further below
so let's take a look at the image this
is a picture of tiger woods
hitting a driver from the rear view
at the top of his backswing and the
reason i chose this image is because
it's a little bit challenging
and makes a nice example his upper body
notice is at right angles to his lower
body so his lower body is facing to the
right of the camera and his upper body
is actually facing the camera and then
his
left arm is occluding his right shoulder
so that's going to make things
um a little more complicated
and let's continue on uh to the next
section
so now we're at the point uh where we're
ready to go ahead and
pre-process our image i recall that when
networks are trained they're trained um
with training images that have a
specific
size and potentially some scaling
performed on them and we need to make
sure that whatever images we're using to
perform inference
on uh are pre-processed in the same way
so here we're setting the net input size
of 368 by 368
and then we're calling the uh opencv
function blob from image
and recall from a previous video that
this takes several arguments related to
all this preprocessing
and then it's also going to convert the
image into a blob
representation which will pass into this
set input function
uh to prepare the network for inference
so let's review these arguments uh
briefly so this first argument
is the image itself and then the second
argument is a scaling factor
which is the same scaling factor that
was applied to the training images so we
need to
perform that same transformation here on
the input image
and then here we're just indicating the
net input size which we just
talked about right here above 368 by
368.
uh the there was no mean value
subtracted from the um
training images so we're simply uh
indicating a vector of zeros here
and then the swap red blue uh flag here
set to true
and uh we're not cropping we're going to
resize our input image
uh to match uh the size of the images
that were used during training which was
368 by 368.
so now we're ready to use the model to
perform inference on our test image and
we do that right here by calling the
forward method
and that returns for us the output from
the network which consists of both
confidence maps and affinity fields
and as we mentioned earlier we're only
going to be using the confidence maps
for
performing the key point detection in
this demonstration
and so for each point we're going to
receive a probability map
and then we're simply going to in this
next two lines of code plot each of
these probability maps
and you'll see that these are color
coded they're heat maps indicating the
probability
of the location of the detected key
point and so red is a very high
probability so in each of these uh
probability maps you'll see this is the
likely location for key point zero
key point one key point two and so forth
so remember this one corresponds to the
head this
corresponds to the neck this corresponds
to the right shoulder and so forth
so we can use these probability maps to
overlay those key points on the original
image and to do that we're going to have
to
scale these in the same scale as the
input image and so that's
what this next block of code is
performing
so right here we're using the uh output
shape of the network
in other words the shape of the
probability maps and also the input
shape of the test image
to compute two scale factors x and y
that we'll end up using below to
determine the location of the key points
in the actual test image
but before we do that we're going to
need to determine the location of the
key points in the probability maps
so that's what we're going to do in this
next code block here
this for loop is looping over all the
key points
and for each key point we're going to
retrieve the probability map
from the output array from the network
and then we're going to call this
opencv function min max location
and pass it the probability map and this
is going to return for us
the location of the point associated
with the
maximum probability and
so the coordinates of the point are in
this variable here point
and then once we have that location in
the um probability map
coordinates we're going to multiply it
by the x and y scale factors we computed
above
to get the key point location in the
original test image
and then if the probability returned by
this function
is greater than some minimum threshold
which we set above
then we're going to go ahead and
take that x y point now in the
coordinates of the test image and then
append it to a list of points
and so now we're ready to render those
points on the test image so
let's scroll down here to our results
first let's just take a look at the
image so this is um
the input image here with all the key
points annotated
on the frame and then the image to the
right is um
the same key points but without the
numbers but with the linkages connected
so two different views of the same data
really
and um if you take a look at this area
that we knew was going to be difficult
in other words
the head was at zero the neck was at one
the right shoulder at two the right
elbow at three the right wrist at four
it looks really nice
even though the left arm is occluding
the um right shoulder
and uh i mean if you go back over here
to the image on the right you can see
the skeletal view and that looks pretty
um
spot on so it did a nice job of
detecting the key points and
and putting them together in a way that
makes sense
but let's just go ahead and walk through
this code a little bit so
up here on these first two lines we're
just making a copy of the input image
and one's gonna be
um called points and the other one's
gonna be called skeleton
and then we're gonna loop over all the
points
that were that we just created in the
for loop above
and those are the coordinates of the key
points in the test image coordinate
frame
and then we're going to use the opencv
circle and put text functions
to draw and label those points on the im
points image which was the um image to
the left down here
and then further we're going to render
the skeleton view
uh that's displayed down here to the
right with this for loop
so we're looping over all the pose pairs
which we defined
further up in the notebook and then
we're retrieving those pairs and we're
going to set those to
part a and part b here and then use
those as indices into the points list
that we created up above which contains
the list of
key point locations in the test image
and now we're simply going to use
opencv line and circle functions to
draw a line from one joint to the next
and color code it and then also draw a
circle at the first
key point in that link so and then here
we're just
using im show to display both these
images below so that's all there is to
it there wasn't much code in this
notebook
since we're leveraging the capability of
opencv to perform inference for us
really the code amounts to a few
function calls
and then a little bit of a logic
to parse the outputs and and render the
information on the original
image and just for fun i went ahead and
ran the same model on a photo of my son
who also plays golf and this is a
view of his follow through and the model
does a pretty good job but
i'll have you notice one thing here is
that the um
if you look over here to the right the
neck and the right shoulder
are off a little bit for some reason so
uh this is the head this is point zero
this is point one which should be right
here
and this is the right shoulder which
should be over here but notice his right
shoulder is actually
occluded uh quite a bit by his back so
it's almost
not even visible so it's it's definitely
a challenging pose
and you know it was a lot of fun to try
this out so
the main point though is that you can
use a pre-trained model
leverage uh the inference capabilities
of opencv
and start playing around with your own
images and video and uh
we think you'll enjoy doing this and
thanks so much and that's all we wanted
to cover in this video and
we'll see you next time well thanks
everybody i hope you enjoyed the course
that we just covered in the getting
started series in computer vision
we covered a lot of ground and a lot of
material uh at a pretty good level for a
getting started series
and i think this is a good opportunity
for us to talk with
dr satya malik who's the ceo of
opencv.org
to get his uh take on how do you get a
job in computer vision for example and
some of the other course offerings uh
that we offer on opencv.org thanks a lot
bill
uh it's a pleasure to talk to this
audience
because they have just completed their
first steps
in opencv and i can understand you know
uh it's very exciting it's a very
exciting field
and the next thing uh people ask is how
do you get a job
in computer vision and ai and the path
is
uh you know you have to dedicate
yourself you have to commit yourselves
to learning
uh various aspects of computer vision
but there is a path
through which you commit to that path
you will find a job at the end of this
path and as you know you know bill
your own journey is one great example of
that
you started your journey in aeronautics
and astronautics
you did your masters from mit in that
area and for the longest time you were
in that
area but then you made a switch
because of your in your job you wanted
to use ai
but then gradually you made a switch to
computer vision and ai
i would you know i would in fact love to
hear that we can start with that little
story
yeah sure i mean i'm excited to talk
about that so i did i worked in the
space and defense industry for many
years uh very rewarding experience
i loved the idea of space travel when i
was a young child
and ended up graduating with a degree in
aeronautics and astronautics and
it was a wonderful experience for me
along the way i had the opportunity
to work on a project that involved
something completely unrelated to what i
was doing i was working
uh managed doing uh performing technical
management on a project related to
machine learning uh at the time and this
was about eight or nine years ago
and uh it's really uh exciting for me to
see just how
um stunning the results were to some of
these use cases that we were working on
it was a small research project and
shortly after that project i uh began a
journey on
on expanding my continued education i
studied machine learning
and also image processing and as i moved
forward with that i really
uh felt a strong passion for working in
the field of computer vision so
i spent quite a bit of time uh taking
extra classes while working full-time
early morning study sessions and uh lots
of weekends
uh spent uh learning all this material
and
uh i'm happy to say that i've landed in
a very nice place and i'm
working in the field full time now and
uh i really
enjoy it thank you yeah so that that's
you know uh
and you took uh deep learning with
pytorch which is
one of our courses uh as well right
right
um so you know so what i was saying is
that there is a path it's
not necessarily easy especially if you
are working full-time you have to
dedicate your nights and weekends
but there is definitely a path for
people who are interested
and if you're a student there is a very
clear path right it's an
a relatively easy path one one
thing i like to say people is that if
you want to learn
about physics you have like 200
years of history in physics so you have
to learn all that material to get
started in physics right before you can
contribute
uh in physics but for computer vision
it's a relatively new field
computer vision you can say that even
though research started in
1960s it's really now
that algorithms that work in the real
world
are uh are available to the general
public so
you're literally talking about a decade
uh of
uh worth of techniques which is not you
know which is not a lot frankly
so for people who are trying to start in
this area i would say that
uh you know set aside and especially
people who are not doing it full-time
they should set aside anywhere between
six months to a year
to learn the material um to get you know
completely
uh and that's that's hard work right six
months to a year
of hard work nights and weekends to
uh get their foothold in this field
where you can think about making a
career switch
you know there are other people in our
courses who
were able to make a switch by taking
just one course
but i usually recommend that you know
you need to be
conver you need to understand
traditional computer vision algorithms
and you also need to learn deep learning
algorithms
so uh you need to have a flavor of both
of those things
let me actually start by explaining
where
uh what are the various aspects of ai so
that
we lay out the land and then it will be
easy for beginners to understand
what are the various topics we are
talking about now uh
the first question you know people ask
is what is artificial intelligence
so it's a very fuzzy term it doesn't uh
it doesn't refer to a specific technique
but in general whenever we try to make
machines
uh think like humans we call it
artificial intelligence
and there are various ways of solving
this problem you can think about a
rule-based system where you're encoding
all the rules
uh like in a chess game you could say
that oh if you do this i'm going to
do this step right and that used to be
very popular uh a few decades back but
then
people realized that uh you can actually
train the machine by giving it data
not explicitly telling it you know what
the rules are
but it will automatically figure out
things based on data
so that's machine learning machine
learning is a subset
of ai techniques where we care about
data
the other part is deep learning you
might you might have heard a lot about
this new uh kind of technique called
deep learning which is nothing but
solving machine learning problems using
a deep neural
networks and you know in our course we
tell you why it is called deep it's a
very subtle
uh thing why it is called deep neural
networks
but it is basically solving ai problems
using neural networks
so that's deep learning computer vision
is actually
there is an overlap of computer vision
deep learning
etc computer vision basically means the
analysis
of images and videos and it is different
from image processing because in image
processing
you have an input image and the output
is also an image
uh you could be encoding an image you
could be
uh you know enhancing an image etc so
that
all is under uh image processing in
computer vision usually we have an
input image and the output is
is information that we want so the image
could be
this video session but the output could
be
the faces that we detected right so it
is
image in and information out not only
that in computer vision we also handle
many things that have nothing to do with
artificial intelligence for example in
this course uh or in this
video series you learned how to create
panoramas
that is a classical computer vision
technique and it has nothing to do with
artificial intelligence
because you're stitching images together
you're using
the geometry of image formation you're
using all these techniques which are not
really machine learning or ai right
but they are still very useful
techniques so there is an overlap
between
artificial intelligence and computer
vision but computer vision has
does a lot more other things also for
example the whole field of
3d computer vision uh
there used to be very little ai in that
now
even ai is being used to enhance uh
those fields also
so that's uh the general lay of the land
so from the artificial intelligence
standpoint uh or the machine uh computer
vision is like
machine learning for images is one way i
like to think about
that component of it and also image
understanding
is another um way to think about uh
computer vision or the the portion of it
that's uh associated with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
yeah and there are other fields of ai
for example
natural language processing that's
another field
where you deal with text data
we also have speech recognition and
that's another big field
you know for example when you call alexa
there is
an artificial intelligence module that
reads
recognizes your voice does the
processing interprets it
etc so that's the speech processing but
among these different fields i think uh
computer vision
has the biggest potential because if you
look at human visual system
it it spends about 30 percent of its
processing power
on the visual part because visual
information is so rich
and we are also in a lucky spot that
there are so many hundreds of millions
of cameras
uh in this world which are continuously
gathering
data so there is a lot of uh there's a
lot of activity
in the computer vision space you know
even in aerospace for example uh for
military and other applications there
are ton of applications
i mean everybody's mobile devices right
everybody's mobile devices have cameras
so there's all
kinds of uh video and image processing
taking place
yeah and it's going to transform
multiple industries uh we are going to
see
in manufacturing we we see we also do
consulting work and
we see people are using computer vision
in manufacturing
and agriculture in security obviously
in autonomous driving that's a very big
area
so computer vision is everywhere and
that's going to explode
it's already on the rise there are so
many jobs out there
and we will we will show you
right there in the video we will show
you the
pay grades of people who get jobs in
this area
you can see that people make more than a
million dollars
in uh you know companies like facebook
etc
of course these are senior people and
these are level six engineers
who uh you know who are accomplished
they are at the cutting edge
but it gives you a sense of an engineer
is making this is not
this is not like uh entrepreneur or this
is not like
a senior manager this is an ai engineer
making that kind of uh money in big
companies
so that gives you a sense of you know
why it is worthwhile
taking a very hard look at these
emerging fields
as a career option so what about some of
the the course offerings you want to
talk about
uh some of those and yeah sure so
basically uh before even we go there
right
it's instructive to know what are the
things that you need to learn
to get into the field and what are the
libraries you need to learn
uh so the very first thing is that it's
very important to
be very good at uh at coding
uh some of these uh algorithms right
algorithms or building systems so you
should be a very good programmer first
because this is a very engineering
oriented field you need to
be able to write code and python is a
great
uh place to start but don't end there
right
take learn as much as possible if you
want to learn c plus plus
if you need to learn c plus plus learn
it and because it
expands your chances of uh getting a job
so uh but let's start with python right
you have
suppose you have python expertise what
do you need to learn
to get a job first of all as i said that
opencv
is a fundamental library you have to
have good expertise
in using opencv that's number one and
then
there are two other libraries that are
very important one is uh
and this is a deep learning framework
from
facebook it's open source it was
developed at facebook
and uh the second one is tensorflow and
kira's
so this library is developed by google
also open source these are all very good
libraries
and if you have mastery over these
three libraries and you have mastery
over computer vision
and uh deep learning techniques i think
there is no way in the world you will
not get a job it's
very easy to get a job once you have
these
uh two or three things under your belt
so uh for from our course point of view
computer vision one covers
traditional computer vision applications
uh
and not so much deep learning we show
you how to use deep learning
uh in applications but we don't show you
how to train deep learning models
computer vision 2 is all about
applications
and there we we go over many different
applications we don't even worry about
you know which library you are choosing
we expose you to several libraries
that will allow you to you know you just
build uh your arsenal
of techniques and libraries and tools
that you can use to build
real-world applications and the third
course is
deep learning with pytorch where you go
over the fundamentals
of deep learning and
we and it starts using pytorch and by
the end of this year
uh 2021 we will also launch uh deep
learning with tensorflow and keras
so basically it's all covered anything
related to
computer vision that involves deep
learning
it's covered in these courses we go over
image classification
object detection image segmentation pose
estimation etc
but these are very meaty courses in the
sense that
we go over uh all the theoretical
details
we uh you will learn about you know what
is back propagation and things like that
so it's once you take these courses
i think uh it is equivalent to taking uh
being getting a master's in computer
vision and machine learning you will get
that level of knowledge in fact i can
very easily say that by the time i
completed my masters
i had i did not have this knowledge that
people gain by taking computer vision
one
and deep learning let's say even if you
take these two courses
computer vision one and deep learning
with pytorch
i did not have that knowledge after my
master's right
so uh and i can say that without uh
without any hesitation
these are solid courses we took the best
from
uh you know various things we we are
also very
industry oriented right we are very very
applications oriented
so we picked the topics that are
actually used in the industry
and left out the things that are only of
theoretical importance
right so what about the prerequisites
people might be wondering about what
what's actually required to get started
and maybe what are the
potential learning tracks here with uh
three or four courses that we offer
yeah so the prerequisite is just uh you
know
intermediate level of knowledge and the
python programming language
once you have that you don't need any
other uh prerequisites
but if you're starting you know you have
never tried uh opencv you're just
starting out
i would suggest that take our first
course opencv for beginners
and that is meant to be a quick you know
a very short and fun course it is short
it is affordable and it is
uh something that you can try in a month
uh
and that will give you an idea you know
do you actually enjoy
building applications do you actually
enjoy this field of uh computer vision
and ai
and once you have completed that course
and you're certain that you want to
invest
uh you know time and energy into this
field
then i would say that uh take computer
version one
which is uh about classical computer
vision we also cover some deep learning
but it's very important to have the
foundation uh ready
a lot of people i see they directly jump
into
uh deep learning that's also an option
but then what happens is that in real
world
there are many problems that you don't
solve using deep learning it's just
absurd to use that technique for solving
uh
some very easy problems in computer
vision and if you don't have that
foundational stuff
you know you will try to look for a nail
because you have this deep learning
hammer
exactly yeah so right so that is a
pitfall that people
should avoid so uh so computer vision
one is the second
one uh you can also skip opencv for
beginners
if you are convinced that oh you want to
commit three to four months
uh you can directly take computer vision
one and
then take deep learning with pytorch
if you have more time to invest let's
say you're a student
then you should definitely take the
whole you know
four courses or at least uh start with
computer vision 1 computer vision 2
deep learning with pytorch and then when
deep learning with tensorflow
and kiras comes along that is also
going to be very useful so computer
vision
um there's uh must be a little bit
overlap between computer vision one and
computer vision two but computer vision
two
is more application focused yep uh is it
considered a little bit more advanced
or what are the prerequisites for that
it's not advanced but we don't
dive into a lot of theory in that we are
more interested in teaching people about
uh the tools right for example if we
cover something like uh like a barcode
or a qr code scanner
we will tell you oh this is the library
this is the best library to use for this
application but we may not go into how
qr code is actually read
right right so we don't go into that
level of detail uh similarly we cover
applications related to faces and
uh you know face swapping and things
like that and
in those cases we go over some theory
enough for you to understand
you know what's what's going on but uh
we may not go into the theoretical
detail of say uh
facial landmark detection which can be
mathematically challenging for people
right right so yeah so it is based on
you build applications right that's the
main focus
we will teach you how to build web
applications for example
so you get exposed to a wide variety of
applications
one thing that i noticed just in my own
continued education in this area was
that
having a little bit of overlap is
actually i found it to be a valuable
experience because
you might cover uh one particular topic
in a class and then
hit it again in another class maybe from
a slightly different perspective or just
the the passage of time and you're
looking at the at the same topic again
you know several months later from a
slightly different vantage point
i found is a actually very helpful so
actually that's true about our deep
learning with pytorch
and deep learning with tensorflow
courses as well
you may ask you know uh if i have taken
deep learning with pytorch does it make
sense for me to take
deep learning with tensorflow as well
and the short answer is yes absolutely
uh you know tensorflow is the most
popular deep learning library in the
world
and pytorch is the one that is rising
the fastest
um a lot of people like using pytorch
because it's very pythonic for
for python developers the learning curve
is uh
very you know it's very gentle you can
easily pick up
uh pytorch but when you go to the
industry
right you're looking for a job right you
want to offer
the best uh things you have
you know you cannot say pytorch is the
library of my choice i don't work in
tensorflow then
people are not going to hire you the the
people who actually use tensorflow
as engineers we should not be married to
the tools right we are there to solve
problems
and if taking this course deep learning
with tensorflow
the theory is already covered in deep
learning with pytorch also
so there will be an overlap and there
will be a reputation
but uh it will be in the context of a
new course right so you are actually
uh looking at uh from a different
framework right
tensorflow is a different framework and
we have also added we are also adding
new applications
so that there is uh you get different
applications with these
uh two courses but with let's say 30
extra effort you learn a new framework
right and now
you have covered everything with pytorch
and tensorflow you are all set in deep
learning
and you also know the theory from when
you take either course we cover the
theory
that is necessary so i think that uh
what you said
uh it also is a revision of your theory
when you take
the second course and um you know people
should not be married to tools and i
i say this about other
python and c plus also uh python is
definitely the first and the easiest
language
uh to get started with uh ai but
don't ignore c plus plus completely
because when you go to the job market
you may find that there are equal number
of jobs in two
areas right and you've already learned
you've done the hard work of learning
the basics the foundation
and you're now you're just worried about
you know i don't like this language or
that language is hard
language is just a way of solving
problems right we should not be married
to one particular language because as
engineers we try to we want to
see ourselves as problem solvers and
whatever is the right tool for the
problem we'll use that
right and two of our courses computer
vision one and computer vision two
they are offered in both languages in
fact when you purchase one course
the other course is for free right so
now you can actually compare code side
by side to see
uh oh this is how it is done in c plus
plus version of opencv
that's really great i like that feature
especially
i think that's great um so we talked
about
python versus c plus plus uh earlier but
i think some people might be wondering
uh obviously both would be good to have
under your belt but some people might be
wondering
to what extent is either language used
in industry and if you only knew one
language very well
or you had an affinity for one of those
languages for for whatever reason
um you know what is the market share for
that language in industry
yeah so um python is definitely it is
fast becoming the language of scientific
computing
but then uh you know there is you you
can easily learn the concepts
using python and it will also be there
are several jobs you know there are
the large i would say 50 of the jobs
would easily take
somebody who has python skills but then
there is this whole other world of
embedded computer vision for example
where you're trying to do computer
vision
on really not very powerful devices
right you're not using a gpu
even if you're using a gpu it's like an
embedded gpu or something
in those cases uh a lot of times these
algorithms are implemented in c
plus plus right and sometimes even in c
right
in c so that because you don't have
access to that much computational power
and that's a lot of you know that's also
a very big market think about all the
security cameras
uh all kinds of devices which are
embedded
uh so i i mean
if you love one language you know
python is great you know try python you
will gradually
uh learn c plus plus over time
what i want to emphasize is that don't
uh think that you're a python developer
only
right think about yourself as an
engineer and you will learn
and uh whatever needs to be learned to
make yourself fit for the job market all
right so
um you know one thing people might be
wondering is there's certainly a lot of
uh freely available course material uh
on the internet um universities are
offering all their court
many top universities are offering many
of their courses online for free
there's lots of tutorials uh what how do
people sort this out and
what do your courses provide that maybe
is not um
available online for free yeah so i
actually encourage people to look at all
the free stuff
uh first right because it builds uh the
confidence it builds the momentum they
start knowing what to expect you know
what they want to learn
uh so they start having an expectation
what they want to learn
so by all means you know there are a lot
of free tutorials on opencv.org and also
on learnopencv.com
go ahead and try those and uh there are
several other very good bloggers also
who uh you can try
and then there are free uh courses by
universities as well
try those as well but then at some point
you know if you feel that you're missing
a structure sometimes what happens is
that
you take all these pieces but you don't
get a bigger picture you know
uh pieces of computer vision but you're
not confident enough to go
and uh present yourself in front of a
job interviewer because
you know that you know you have learned
in bits and pieces
you have not connected the dots
completely
and that can be a blow to your
confidence right when you take a course
it is structured
and you know that the important things
have been covered and
suppose the interviewer asks you
something which is beyond what you have
learned you can confidently say that oh
i have not learned that that's okay
but i know uh this thing i have gone in
a
through a structured path to learn all
these things
and in our courses we also cover uh you
know
there's a lot of code that people go
through you you write a lot of code i
was saying that you need to be very good
at programming
so you need to write a lot of code you
you know read a lot of code
so that's a very good practice we also
give you assignments and projects
and together that uh creates you know
sense of urgency it
creates a sense of responsibility that
you have to finish this thing
what happens with online material is
that you take this
and you read the code but you never
write any code right you feel that you
have understood it
but if you take away that code you
cannot ever write
from scratch right you use that material
as a crutch
so when you start doing something like a
project etc
uh it actually comes together right you
feel
you need to job market it's basically a
confidence game you need to have
your expertise to a level where you're
confident uh
you can uh face an interviewer right
and then we also uh not only that you
know
on the internet in a blog format it is
simply not possible to cover
things uh in depth right so
a lot of times uh people gloss over
things
and we do that ourselves also it's
simply not possible to go
in a blog format you have to condense
everything uh to be easily
uh consumable you don't have that user
uh for an hour right so you have to make
sure that they learn
whatever they want to learn in 10
minutes and
in doing so the medium is restricted in
some sense
so in courses we don't have that
restriction we know that people are
committed
they are ready to spend time on this and
so we
take the time to explain in depth uh
that's
that's a very important thing as well
and there is also peer pressure
when you see that other people are you
know asking questions in the course
forum they are
um they are enjoying the course it puts
a little bit of pressure on you
in a positive way which uh which propels
you that i also want to do something
uh you know well you're all in it
together right it's a little bit of
camaraderie too
and uh i think you said it perfectly
that confidence comes from
mastery so you feel confident when you
know that you've mastered one particular
topic
and then the other thing that you
brought up is uh doing projects so
uh um actually executing a project and
taking what you've learned to create you
know an extension of that
uh is i think very valuable very
rewarding and also
it forces you not to skip steps so you
could be reading a blog or watching a
video online and not in your head yes
this all makes sense
but when it comes time to actually code
something or create something
a little bit different than what you
learned if you actually have to program
it and get your hands dirty
it forces you not to skip steps or gloss
over details that are actually
required so right i think that's a very
valuable experience
so let's talk a little bit about what uh
sort of jobs are available
in industry i mean some immediate ones
come to mind the entertainment industry
perhaps uh medical imaging uh
manufacturing but
what are the different uh domains and
and uh types of
uh fields where computer vision is
actually being used
more recently so uh professor andrewing
who is also the founder of coursera he
likes to say that
ai is like electricity so when
electricity was invented
it was used in for lighting purposes but
within a few years it transformed
multiple industries it was used in
manufacturing in agriculture
and a lot of different things and ai has
the same power right it is used in
certain industries right now
but it is transforming multiple
industries including manufacturing
automotive you know uh autonomous
driving cars
um and agriculture we have a lot of
people who are working
on pest control who are working on
removing weeds
in an agricultural setting there are
medical imaging is huge
because now ei is doing better than
radiologists in some sections right
because when the data becomes available
and it's a repetition some tasks which
are repetitive
in those cases you know we are ai is
going to do better
than humans over time as the data
becomes
available it is those creative fields
you know
let's say even in music and creating
generating new images
ai is learning from existing data and
creating a
new art form right but
there are certain fields where ai is not
going to take over
uh for example um comedy is one example
comedy is you cannot train uncommon
you know the if you if you look at the
jokes that are produced by
an ai system they're usually pretty lame
they try to rhyme something
because for creating comedy you need
things that come that's in
that's not in a specific area you could
tell a joke
which combines uh you know something
going on in the music industry
with something that is going on in
sports and when you put them together it
is funny
right right it's really hard to to how
do you quantify that right
right and it's not domain specific
because you took something
very different in a completely different
domain and combined it with something
uh very different and so those kinds of
things which are one off right and it's
even best comedians do not know what
will
what will fly right so they do a lot of
tests themselves right right those kinds
of fills
fields are very difficult uh you know
for ai but everywhere else
where it is very structured like
manufacturing it's a very structured
environment
uh warehouses uh it's a very structured
environment a very controlled
environment right so
a lot of variation is removed in those
cases so which makes it easier a lot of
variations are removed and there are
repetitive tasks
that can generate a lot of data right
the the
key thing is that they are repetitive
tasks the same task is happening over
and over again
no matter how complex the task you can
put a camera there
and get as much data as possible as
as you want and ultimately that problem
will be solved right
so um i mean if you look at all the
companies
who are the companies hiring when i
graduated back in 2006
i had a few options i could go to
microsoft research i could go to google
i could go to a few
different places but now the people who
come to us for consulting
they are all over the place obviously
these these big companies are still
there microsoft google
facebook adobe all these companies are
still there who hire
computer vision research engineers but
then there are
small companies one or you know like
five people companies
who are working on uh something very
specific that you may not have thought
about
uh but they need computer vision
expertise for example one of the first
consulting projects
uh i did they were sorting lego pieces
so these lego pieces there are 10 000 of
those we don't realize it but
there are 10 000 unique uh lego pieces
and they wanted to identify with
reliability which piece
it is right so because they wanted a
replacement system that if some
piece is lost they can replace it so
uh you can see that that is something
that came
out of the blue i had never thought
about you know uh oh
that's an application area right right
another one was
uh uh there were there is a company that
is using
uh uh computer vision for detecting
the species of fish when they have uh
you know when they catch fish
they want to make sure just to you know
what is the size of the fish what is the
size
what is the species that they have
caught and things like that so
uh to do that that analysis they are
using computer vision
uh microscopy companies we have worked
on so many different applications
uh even you know applications which have
a huge impact
like um one where they were identifying
uh shooters uh in school and
uh we had worked on a very proof of
concept project
uh with a company and recently a
few weeks back i came to know that they
have grown into a full-fledged company
and they are offering the service
right so my point is that computer
vision is everywhere
it's not just focused on these large
companies
but i just gave you several examples
i'll add one more example there is a
company
that used us for detecting fraud
in fashion merchandise like bags these
bags are very expensive some of them are
two thousand dollars
for a small bag by a recognized brand
and they want to protect
the brand identity so they want to
something that is two thousand dollars
you can make a very good copy of that
for a thousand dollars right
and then sell it for two hundred dollars
and still make a very good profit
so um but fortunately these companies
have very high standards
trained a machine learning algorithm to
know the difference between
uh between a fraud a bag and the real
bag
so you can see now in the fashion
industry we have worked and this is a
small company you know i'm talking about
a consulting company
uh with 40 50 people
we are receiving such uh diverse set of
uh problems to work on we worked on
sports analytics also where we are
tracking
soccer ball um uh in in a
sports setting there are other companies
who have approached
us for baseball for golf and uh other
you know projects like that one so uh
it's a very diverse range uh we are
lucky to be in this
in this position i'm really really
curious that the example that you
pointed to with the
with the counterfeit merchandise was
that actually was that machine learning
only or did that incorporate deep
learning
it was a deep learning project it was it
was a deep learning project
um and this company basically is in the
business of selling
second-hand they buy these
handbags and then resell them so when
they buy these
handbags from people they have to make
sure that these handbags
are genuine and they have experts
who go and check whether these things
are genuine or not
and that requires a lot of expertise
right even to give a quote
for this for this handbag how much
should it be quoted
you need to know the exact make and ma
the model of the handbag
which is the 10 000 of these again
right so you have to automatically
determine at least to give a get a
ballpark
you know which kind of handbag it is
otherwise there are these
experts who are you know tens of experts
who
are employed just to look at the these
images
and make sure that oh uh this is this
kind of handbag right this is a gucci
handbag of such and such model and
therefore it should be priced at such
and such
um right and then the handbags comes in
and you have to determine whether it is
counterfeit or not
and that requires a different level of
expertise altogether
because mistakes can be really
expensive very expensive right yeah they
are putting their name on that that this
is a genuine item
so we've covered quite a bit in this
discussion today and i just curious if
you had any final thoughts for people
who are
perhaps on the fence about getting into
computer vision or wondering exactly
you know how they might start um
yeah so uh final thoughts uh first of
all don't be
afraid of taking a leap into this field
uh the job opportunities are tremendous
it's a very good uh career switch for
people who
are interested you know the first thing
you have to answer for yourself is are
you
interested in computer vision and ai and
if it
you know sparks joy uh in you
then this field is full of opportunities
high paying jobs etc
and take any learning path right it's
not necessary that you take our courses
which you can but jump into this
uh this learning path try to learn as
much as possible
from free material and when you're ready
come to our courses
but even if you don't it doesn't matter
right the main important thing
is that you embark on this journey
knowing that there are a lot of jobs
available in this area
and if you spend about six months to
about a year
and dedicate your time and energy into
this
you can become an expert an engineer who
can
uh create you know who can join this ai
revolution
so with that in mind i wish you all the
best welcome to the ai revolution
you